race has no root in biology but the
impacts of race are still felt you think
America is a racist country yeah I'm not
sure the black people have more rights
today black people don't have anywhere
near the right to life that they had
before roie Wade which is why more black
babies mured in the room in New York
City born to teach you about some like
racial issues can a man become a
woman this isn't an Ultras no this is a
9we fetus in a pet tree dish in a pet
tree dish it's just really ghastly to
show a picture of a person who
these debates usually take place in The
Matrix one person in One Digital
Universe and then another person in
another Digital Universe and its
reactions on reactions on reactions and
it's it's too much it's not conducive to
human flourishing or productive
discourse and so today I have invited JJ
and he's graciously accepted to come on
over here and have this discussion in
person this episode is brought to you by
expressvpn more from them in a moment
now though JJ thank you for being here
absolutely anytime and it's not going to
stop keep going we're going to keep
going back and forth in The Matrix after
this absolutely it doesn't stop it's my
job now this all started because I was
talking to another young liberal lady
and I made the claim that when you have
sex with somebody you are consenting to
the possibility of pregnancy and you
found this very objectionable no no that
that was you agree with that no yeah I
do agree that you're consenting to the
possibility of pregnancy but you said um
you're consenting to the possibility of
pregnancy and she agreed and you said
well if it's consent to the possibility
then it is consent to pregnancy that's
what I took the issue with because I
don't believe in any other scenario do
we hold the concept of consenting to an
action means that you're consenting to
every feasible outcome of that action
but but the possibility of pregnancy the
the only end of that is pregnancy I'm
not saying the possibility of pregnancy
or this or that or some other thing
saying the the Poss possibility that
this action will result in a pregnancy
would I I don't I don't understand what
the distinction would be what do you
mean only end of that just the term
possibility means that something could
happen so there's multiple possible
outcomes of sex right so one thing that
i' like to pull from is not just the
pregnancy aspect cuz again I mentioned
to you in one of our videos going back
and forth that humans have sex for
multiple reasons and you took a little
issue because you said well there's
supposed to only be one reason but no no
there are multiple reason
but there but some reasons more
important than others yeah and I would
say that um especially if we're looking
at what sex is naturally ordered to Sure
producing Offspring is one of them but
also communication relationship bonding
those are all very critical things that
also take part in a relationship you can
even have sex with a person and not
further that relationship there are
various things that you that take place
well you you'll further some sort of
relationship you'll further a
relationship but that if you want to do
hookups or if you wanted to do like a
one night stand or whatever it could
take place but you you don't need to
furtherly engage with that person so
that now what if you have the hookup or
the one night stand and maybe you're
even using artificial contraception but
it doesn't work or it breaks and the
girl gets pregnant well then you're not
going to have anything to do with her
that relationship's not going to go any
further well no I think you could have
nothing to do with somebody regardless
of whether or not they get pregnant you
but I'm asking in this specific Cas in
this specific instance then it depends
on what the two people want if you guys
like each other enough you want to stay
together I'm not saying that you
necessarily need to be like like kick
them to the curve I don't even know
where that necessarily comes from but
again sex has multiple different
possibilities it could be that someone
gets pregnant after that point it could
you want to still further the
relationship you could say you don't
want to further the relationship that's
not necessarily what the point is the
point is but if you don't further the
relationship then you would be
abandoning your child and the the woman
that you've you've left I'm going to
take issue with that a little bit
because I feel like you are there's this
concept of an intuition pump right so if
we use the term child intuition pum an
intuition pump yeah so essentially it's
when you push loaded emotional
connotations into words that don't
necessarily them in a given scenario so
for example if you're to say a child
right me and you aren't dumb when we
colloquially use the term child we're
refer we're referring to birthed people
people who are already born no I I I
refer to offspring yeah Offspring I mean
see I can understand why you can use the
term Offspring right because you are
still referring to offspring when you
say the word child but if I say child or
kid or even baby those all three things
are connotated of people who are born
and those are actually definitions I
don't think so I mean when for instance
when my wife first became pregnant with
our first child when when before the
baby was born people would ask oh how's
the baby doing I would think about my
future son my my child I'd get the
bedroom ready we'd start buying clothing
so I I certainly when when I would refer
to my child I would be referring to the
baby in the womb you do you know why you
were referring to to it as a child
because it's my child yeah I mean yeah
but also under the you were under the
impression that that child was going to
be born correct when people ask how's
the baby doing and and that also works
the other way because a lot of times you
can say it's impolite to ask necessarily
if you don't know someone's pregnant or
you don't want to call someone fat yeah
you don't want to call someone fat but
you also don't want to assume that like
either everything is just peachy or that
they want to keep that pregnancy well I
want to assume that someone is not going
to murder her child I I do make well
that you're factually wrong on that
because murder is a specific legal
definition you could say it should be
murder but if you're going to assume
that they're going to murder their child
that is assuming that the killing is
unlawful and that's also assuming that
abortion is it is unlawful because it's
it is notely moral law maybe but not law
law I I don't know what I don't know
what law you're talking about which
abortion is the natural law and the
moral law from which we derive the civil
and you mean natural law and moral law I
mean laws that are true for all people
at all times so we have certain civil
laws and positive laws you know uh the
state of Louisiana might have a
different kind of traffic law than the
state of New York but there are certain
laws like um it is wrong to commit
murder that are true for all people at
all times yes so and and so the way that
we get our civil law and our positive
law is in part by uh deducing certain
conclusions from the moral and natural
yeah but you're also shoehorning in the
legal term while trying to Define why
it's wrong for like everybody murder
murder has been understood to be wrong
since yeah no what I mean by that is
that the term murder is the unlaw
killing of a person right but if someone
kills somebody in self-defense that's
not an unlawful killing it's still
killing yeah it wouldn't be murdered
right so you can't say that necessarily
like oh it is murder when it isn't
because the killing in this instance the
termination of the pregnancy which would
entail the death of the fetus is lawful
so it's not an unlawful no no it's notw
oh because you believe that it shouldn't
be lawful or you believe we have a
difference of of opinion here you say
that it is it is lawful that's the fact
that's the reality the opinion though
that's a fact that's not even an opinion
it is lawful what do you think an
opinion is opinion is something that's
subjective up to your interpretation on
the books the law is that abortion is
not murder so if you say abortion is
murder you are factually incorrect so
before we get back to abortion for a
second I think you're mistaken about the
meaning of the word opinion because you
seem to be conflating an opinion with a
preference do you do you understand the
distinction between the two there is a
distinction between the two but that's
not the connotation which I was using
well you were saying an opinion is
subjective right
in the way that a preference is
subjective you know I like vanilla more
than chocolate that would be a
preference that's not what an opinion is
an opinion is when you make a statement
of fact from your perspective so here's
how I would show you an example well
that gets into the whole like
alternative fact realm you don't you can
make a a proclamation about what you
perceive the world around you to be and
that can be your opinion but there's a
specific distinction between opinion and
a fact now you can say that like uh a
preference and an opinion are similar in
that they're both subjective that
doesn't mean that necessarily they are
the same thing they're not both
subjective because a preference can't be
wrong whereas an opinion can be wrong so
for instance I can say I think that the
moon is made of green cheese it is my
opinion that the moon is made of green
cheese that is my opinion but it's wrong
I could also say that uh I think the sun
is shining outside today and that would
also be my opinion but it would be
correct so some opinions can be correct
and some can be because there statements
of fact from your perspective no some
opinions can be some opinions can be
correct and some opinions can be wrong
because of the underlying data and the
underlying evidence that is to reality
to which they refer yeah so you can say
that it is your opinion that the sun is
shining and that's also an opinion that
is based off of the fact that the sun
gives off light but you could also say
it's my opinion that it's made out of
that the moon is made out of cheese but
there's literally no evidence to back
that up so I think reducing it yeah I
think reducing it down to a preference
versus an opinion is kind of trying to
misc conscrew the words there no no
because I I could have a preference you
know I could say I like cigars which I
do and you don't like cigars and that's
my preference and that's your preference
neither of those is wrong they're just
our tastes
and as we say but I could say a cigar is
made of tobacco and you could say a
cigar is made of green cheese and I
would be right and you would be wrong
but that's not a statement of fact from
your perspective that's what that's what
you believe to be a fact which is what
an opinion is so you can't
a so I have a preference of what type of
cigar whatever those two things cannot
be wrong but if you're saying an opinion
is really a statement of fact from your
perspective that's you said that's what
you believe to be a fact it's not a fact
so that's what I'm saying if you get
into this realm where it's like a fact
is entirely dependent on what you
perceive it is that inherently means
that one person cannot have a wrong
opinion but you said that one person
can't have a wrong opinion it's not that
the the fact relies upon my perception
it's that that my perception can
accurately or inaccurately uh describe
the fact so I I could say this is a
glass of
Seltzer I think this is a glass of
Seltzer it is not a glass of Seltzer
because it is my opinion that it is it
is my opinion that it is a glass of s
because it actually is in fact but if
you said this is a glass of chocolate
milk and it is my opinion that this is a
glass of chocolate milk your opinion
would be incorrect and your perception
would be defective no I will say I think
that the the way the language is getting
parse here it's like an opinion is a
statement of what is a perceived fact
from your perspective but it's not a
statement of fact from your because you
see where the distinction is you can't
say that it's a statement of fact from
your perspective it's a declaration
you're saying I think this I think X but
in reality the truth is actually y so if
you're saying oh it's a yeah but if
you're saying it's a statement of fact
from my perspective if I say I think X
you it's a fact that you think X but
that's the as far as it can go it's not
really a fact from your perspective I
feel like the reason why I'm making the
distinction here is cu it's kind of like
putting my subjective like opinion on
the same level as like cuz it's like oh
you can't say that I'm wrong because
it's a fact from my perspective that's
kind of maybe I'm reading into what
you're saying wrong but that's kind of
the vibe I get I get the alternative
fact Vibe where it's like I'm not sure
what vibe that is that's that's the
that's the that's the you know trumpist
Vibe the thing that I'm getting where
it's like you can see people in a crowd
and like well it's my opinion that I had
the big
inauguration size of all time and that's
just an alternative fact cuz it's from
my
perspective digital audience he actually
did but that's a topic for another
digital audience is crazy I don't think
Obama was pulling too much on the live
stream forums in 2008 he probably wasn't
yeah exactly that's why that's why that
such a statement would be true too but
but uh I I guess the reason it's
important to clear this up is because we
have a disagreement here over whether a
baby in the womb is a baby is morally
significant in the way that you and I
are morally significant we have a
disagreement you say I think that well
no actually what you're saying is it is
simply a fact that the baby's not a baby
and I'm saying it is my opinion that the
baby is a baby no I we have a difference
of opinion but but at most one of us is
going to be right no my statement of
fact was that abortion wasn't murder
because but but that would presuppose
that the baby is not a baby if the baby
is a baby then abortion would be murder
right because you'd be you'd be
unlawfully killing a person well no
because again when you say the word
unlawfully you're talking about your
moral like your moral no I'm I'm
speaking of the objective moral yeah and
the law in the United States is that
abortion is not murder if they overruled
it and said yes now abortion is murder
then it would be murder but you can't
say abortion is murder because it's
unlawfully killing a baby or a person or
whatever when it is lawful in many
states abortion is substantially or
entirely illegal according to even the
Civil positive yeah so at at the best
you can have it is kind of sometimes Mur
depending on the state you don't have
caveats in that statement you say it is
murder I guess the I think the mistake
that you're making though is that you're
suggesting that the positive law or the
civil law of the state is the ultimate
law law I'm sorry I'm sorry also the
laws in those states do not rule AB
abortion as murder they'll usually put a
really short time frame that's like
almost impossible for the women to know
that they're pregnant and if you still
have the abortion you still are aborting
that zygote that is unique human DNA but
they don't consider it murder I think
taking it to murder is the Draconian
position where it's like okay well now
we need we need to prosecute as if it w
murder but even Republican states don't
do that no that's not true and including
in liberal states if for instance though
New York just changed it because they
wanted to liberalize abortion but if you
were to murder a pregnant woman you
would be charged with double
murder because you've killed the mother
and you've killed the child and that's
true even in liberal states yeah that is
true and I think rational I think the
rationale behind that that's not saying
the same thing as abortion the process
of terminating a pregnancy is is murder
because the reason why Mur terminates
the pregnancy yeah no the rationale is
because there is no distinguish you
can't predict whether or not a woman is
going to bring a pregnancy to term so if
you have a pregnant woman and you kill
thinking from a legal sense if you have
a pregnant woman and I kill you and then
I kill the woman and then the baby dies
too whatever I get charged double
because we don't know what was going to
happen we're under the impression that
they were going to bring the pregnancy
to term because you it wouldn't really
make sense to prosecute otherwise but
you're not the the murder would not be
charged with murdering the woman and
violating her right to decide whether or
not she wanted to take a pregnancy to
term he charged with is double murder
the reason why they're charged with
double murder is because when you kill
the mother or whatever so that's what
I'm saying abortion is a separate
concept but to be char No because
abortion is abortion is the ability to
terminate a pregnancy right so if you're
killing somebody terminate a pregnancy
well you're us if it's an ectopic
pregnancy then the baby's already dead
but the how did we how did we get to the
topic of ectopic pregnancy because the
procedure is still in the I think is
you're kind of moving away from homicide
no no hold on hold on because I think
you're because the the point wait how am
I moving away from it when you cut me
off and then I'm trying to explain you
why what you just said was wrong what
I'm saying is an ectopic pregnancy you
would still get rid of that pregnancy
via abortion the term abortion is just
the termination of a pregnancy a lot of
times it does result in the and it's the
termination of a nonviable pregnancy in
particular of abortion refers to the
termination of a non-viable pregnancy
how what percent what percentage of
abortions do you think are uh in the
case of ectopic pregnancy or a threat to
the life of the mother oh that's a
different question I'm because what I'm
saying is reason far more than 99% of
abortions are elective where the where
the baby is violent yeah no no that's
you said what you don't understand is
concept of viability 80% of abortions
take place in the first week not the
first week the first you're viable of
living outside of the mother's yes
that's what I'm saying that's why so the
vast majority of the time and the but
the baby would still be viable in as
much as the baby would continue to
develop and live just like that's not
but again you're mincing words cuz
that's not what the term viability mean
you're saying that it's you're saying
it's not euphemism it's literal words I
don't know what euphemism maybe I'm what
do you eism means yeah I know what
euphemism means I'm not using one but
the thing is I'm telling you a euphemism
is a word to try to paper over a harsh
reality with language that would be less
evocative and clear I'm which is why I'm
referring to a human being in the womb
and you're trying to refer to say a
pregnancy or the product hold wait hold
on I didn't say that the pregnancy or
the the fetus isn't a human being it is
but I'm telling you okay good I'm
telling you but then why won't you call
it a human being what I said a pregnancy
I the the reason why I say because I'm
describing what the term abortion refers
to it's referring to ending a pregnancy
meaning it doesn't necessarily mean
killing a human being if the human being
is already dead you'd use the same
procedure but abortion abortion doesn't
operate on people who are already dead
abortion you you could ECT that's why
I'm bringing up ectopic pregnancy the
threat of an ectopic pregnancy is the
baby is continuing to grow and threatens
the life of the mother no that so if if
it's like develops cancer if like the
the cells that are developing into the
baby turned cancerous or there's
something where well the mother could
develop cancer separately which would be
yeah no but I'm saying in terms like
that where the the baby is dead or you
have like a miscarriage or something
like that the process on the process by
which you terminate that pregnancy is
still abortion abortion is simply
referring to terminating a pregnancy of
an unviable fetus which means or a
viable fetus which means that in the
time in which it is terminated it cannot
survive outside the mother that's the
term abortion now you can say abortion
could be used for killing a baby or
everything but that doesn't change the
but it doesn't change the fact that
there are circumstances which the baby's
already dead and that procedure is still
called an abortion so outlawing that
procedure it isn't though is you use the
word terminate what does the word
terminate mean and a pregnancy okay and
what is a pregn what do you mean by a
pregnancy the fetus is inside of the
mother and so so the termination VI what
do you mean when you say you're going to
end the pregnancy by which you say you
mean the fetus that is inside of the
mother but well I don't mean ending the
fetus that is inside the mother I mean
ending the process of pregnancy and what
is that process the process is the
continued growth of that pregnancy which
is which is life yes even if the baby is
no longer growing or something that's
still a pregnancy cuz it's still inside
the mother the ter of a viable pregnancy
is delivery or C-section so I don't
think you understand so the termination
of a nonviable pregnancy would be when
the baby cannot live outside the mother
right and you get an abortion whatever
that's how you or if there that's not an
ectopic pregnancy that could be just any
time before the baby could live outside
of the mother yeah you're okay so we're
no longer just talking about ectopic
pregnancy we're yeah no I was never only
I was never only like trying to make the
point that topic pregnancy is the only
I'm saying the term abortion refers to
ter ating a pregnancy that can be at any
stage of the pregnancy if you terminate
a nonviable pregnancy that is abortion
that is usually what will happen in the
first like few weeks or the first
trimester of uh which is when most
abortions happen when you terminate a
viable fetus meaning a fetus that can
live outside the womb unless it's like
threat to the mother which is very rare
that is a delivery if the pregnancy ends
on a viable fetus that is usually
because the mother has pushed out the
baby or got a C-section you don't like
me using this term baby or person
be you don't like because I think
because I think that you and me and
everyone watching knows that the image
that pops into mind when you say a baby
or a child we say the term how's the
baby how's your baby to a woman who's
pregnant because we're under the
assumption that they are going to bring
that baby to term we kind of that's not
why yes we make that jump that it's like
you're going to get perhaps that's how
you interpret it the way I interpret it
the reason that I would ask how is the
baby doing is because I'm uh inquiring
into how that baby at that particular
moment is doing that's why that's why I
use that language yeah no that's the
same those two but I'm not saying baby
will those two things aren't mutually
exclusive you could actually you could
be you could be inquiring into the
condition of the baby but the reason why
you're using the term baby is because
when you see someone who's pregnant
you're not you don't think about hey do
they want to bring this to do they want
to bring this to term what's going on in
their personal life BR back you see
they're pregnant that means they're
going to have a baby that's brings us
back to the point that's at hand here
because what you seem to be suggesting
here is that the identity of the being
inside the womb is contingent upon
whether or not the mother wants to have
an abortion so if the mother does want
to have an abortion let me at least
explain what I think you're saying and
then you can correct me if I'm wrong
you're saying if the mother wants to
have an abortion and get rid of the baby
then you wouldn't refer to it as a baby
you wouldn't ask how's the baby doing
obviously but if the mother wants to
bring the baby to term and then raise
the baby and send the baby off to
college then you would ask how is the
baby doing and and the question of
whether or not that baby is a baby
depends upon the wishes of the mother as
pertains to that baby is that what
you're saying well no so what I'm saying
is the language that you use right so
when we're using the term baby you don't
there's no point in which you're growing
up through childhood and you stop and
think huh let me comp let me consider
the complex Natures of pregnancy and way
the mother you just kind of assume you
see someone showing they're going to
have a baby how's the baby doing and
most times it's not offensive because
usually if you're getting to the point
where you're showing you're probably
going to already carried the baby to
term but when we're talking about the
fact that vast majority of abortions
happen within the first trimester a lot
of times you're not even showing you
don't or you know drug yeah but yeah and
at that point you don't even really get
the opportunity to ask how's the baby
doing because a lot of times you don't
even know that somebody is pregnant or
they don't even know that they're
pregnant and then they get the thing so
it's like when you see somebody who is
obviously pregnant a lot of times
they're further along they planning for
a baby so we make that jump hey how's
the baby doing because we're under the
assumption that yeah most people going
to bring the baby to but if that baby
okay so if the baby is a baby and you're
going to call B if you asked somebody
hey how's the baby doing then you'd
listen to them and if they're like well
I we're going through some stuff and I
don't know I might I'm looking into
getting an abortion if they get that
close to you I don't know I don't really
equ that information like something
close to me but if you got they got
close to you and they're like yeah I
don't know um you'd probably be better
off if you didn't like oh but your child
how's your child doing but the child
because you know what that's invoking
sure okay so let's leave it at baby if
you're granting that you see a pregnant
woman you say hey hey that's a baby I'm
acknowledging that that thing is a baby
then don't you necessarily have to
conclude that it would be wrong to kill
that baby through an abortion because
you're saying it's a baby well I'm yeah
if you use that language but you just
said you would use that language no I'm
saying yeah if you're saying oh how's
the baby doing and they're like yeah I'm
going to kill this baby no I'm just opin
yeah but I'm saying assuming you support
legal so you get yeah you get two
separate like things right so if you say
oh how's your how's the baby doing and
they're like oh I'm I'm planning on
murdering this baby that's one thing if
you're saying oh how's the baby doing
it's like well I don't really know I
think I'm I'm going through some stuff
with the pregnancy my doctors told me
that XYZ is going to happen or I'm just
not in a position right now I think I'm
going to add my pregnancy that's going
to be fine because most humans can
understand it's like okay this person
doesn't have the this person doesn't
have the I didn't say I didn't say Oh I
thought you said funny no I wouldn't
find that fine why wouldn't you find
that fine well because we both just
agreed that
whatever it is that is inside the
mother's womb is a baby we both agree
that we would you just said baby but
fetus means I'm saying using baby the
reason why we colloquially use the term
baby is because we make the assumption
that they're going to give birth to that
baby it's a lot of times when we see
someone pregnant if they're obviously
showing that they're pregnant they're
probably far long enough to where you
can make the Assumption they're going to
give birth but if I was a medical
professional or if I'm talking about the
concept of pregnancy or a term relating
to that pregnancy like abortion I'd use
the term fetus because we're talking in
scientific terms now there is no room
for we're not talking about oh what
value are we going to assign to this kit
we need to give the give the mother like
a time to actually decide what's going
to happen What does what does the word
fetus mean what does the word fetus mean
it's a stage of human development do you
know the meaning of the word though I
don't know like what are you talking
it's a Latin yeah Oh I thought you okay
I don't know like the Latin Origins it
means Offspring
yes
and yeah so if I say that I have a
teenager at home that's Offspring if I
say I have a child at home that's
Offspring if I say I have a baby at home
that's offspring that all offs three
yeah yeah fetus Offspring you should
kill of them four different stages of
development yeah the same thing yeah but
they all say they all mean Offspring if
I use those same thing with fetus same
thing with everything and so it would be
wrong I'm not saying yeah I'm not saying
that I'm not I'm not saying that using
one word over the other means that it's
not your off your we Grant it's four
stage of the same person so it'd be
wrong to murder your teenager it'd be
wrong to murder your child it'd be wrong
to murder your newborn infant and it
would be wrong to murder the fetus yeah
because if you murdered them then that's
unlawful killing you keep using that
word you can say kill because you
believe that it should be M you think
there's a moral law that exists uh
separate from the positive laws of Any
Given
State a moral law yeah I believe
morality exists I don't believe that
there's a moral Creed that what is
morality
it's a tough question for me I think
morality to me is well I don't know like
kind of what we feel I don't want to say
I don't necessarily because I think it's
a little bit deeper than feeling kind of
like our nature or our feeling of what's
right and wrong I think the way in which
we ground that I like to ground my
Morality In in human well-being um and
trying to like reduce as much harm as
possible but I don't when it comes to
like a specific definition I don't know
if you're looking for like a
dictionary no I think you've gotten
reasonably close though you you make a
good point which is you say I think it's
more Than A Feeling which necessarily it
must be it must be reasonable so if we
are to know anything about morality at
all it's not just going to be from our
feelings which might change with our
passions but it would have to be through
the use of our reason we would know
using our reason that certain things are
better than other things and that
certain things are right and certain
things are wrong yeah but I don't
necessarily like if you're going to say
moral law and that a lot of us like all
of us have a moral core like things that
we tell ourselves like oh I would never
do that or I could never do that I don't
think I have AAL if you mean if you mean
that in like a figurative sense yes but
I don't mean I don't think that there's
like a moral like Declaration of
specific things we all need to live up
to I think we all have an idea of what's
an ideal that we try to live up to and
we try to get as close to that as
possible um and try not the ideal is
objectively true or it's just subjective
what do you mean well it seems to me
you've contradicted yourself a little
which is
you're saying yes we all have an
intuition of morality of ideals that we
would like to live up to but it's not
like a declaration or a law like when I
say that I don't like when I say that I
mean it's like not I know you are
religious I don't believe it's like
Divine like commandment written down
somewhere I think that it's more like
like I said like what we Intuit it what
we feel like strong why do we feel it
why do we feel it I think it's I think
there's a lot of reasons for that I
think a it comes from our being as a
social species our ability to to think
sentient that gets us to think about
some complex stuff even like is what I'm
doing right or wrong how would this make
other people feel I think that that
comes from our evolution of being around
each other having to communicate to
survive having to make compromises see
what's right and wrong recognize that if
we kill each other then we probably just
keep going at it and no one gets any
benefit out of it and it's like it's
those things that kind of develop as hum
but then if if it were merely that uh
you know we don't kill each other
because that would probably produce some
problems for society over time so we
just basically have a truce not to kill
each other that that wouldn't be then to
say that it is wrong to kill someone to
commit murder yeah it would just say
that we just kind of agree to not kill
each other because it's yeah I think I
think that so then so then this is
crucial you're not grasping at an ideal
that you are intuiting you your using
your reason you're just kind of coming
up with a concordat to live together no
but I think that before there's a time
where we can sit across from each other
and discuss what the meaning of right
and wrong is I think that there's a time
where there's these feelings that we
have through our Evolution and
everything where it's like cool I don't
want to kill this person not just
because it's going to cause some
problems down the line but it's like we
can recognize what loss is we can
recognize what we don't want that to
happen to us and it'd probably be better
as our species if we work together to
accomplish things more than we fight and
then that further that same ideal gets
put into words when we get more words to
describe that and we're like okay this
is wrong we don't we don't agree and I
don't think that it's subjective in the
sense that oh we could just decide
what's right and wrong I think it's
objective but that's only given that we
all agree on the framework that we do
all agree on which is well-being so then
but then it wouldn't be objective it
would be relative OB given no it's
objective given uh like a a scope so I
don't think that you can go out and find
morals in the ground but I think if as a
could could you could you deduce morals
using your reason or do you even have a
reason deduce morals using your reason I
think you can use your reason to
understand um and come to a more moral
position yeah I don't think that you can
like I don't think it's like you make it
up but there are certain things that
feel and then you use your reason to get
the so that is that is what I'm getting
at when you keep saying that well
because in certain States the positive
civil law uh has a license for abortion
that therefore it's legal and there's no
moral conundrum here but what I'm
pointing out is that sometimes the
positive civil law is unjust compared to
the objective moral law this is
something like Martin Luther King talk
about a lot that's again you can't you
can't say that it's well I mean you can
say that it's wrong according to the
objective moral law but according to my
objective moral law there is it's not
wrong I just think I think you're wrong
if we but if if if there is a
distinction between your moral law and
my moral law then there can't be an
objective moral law you understand no
cuz we can also we can argue about what
do you value like human well-being oh
yes right and I and I assume that you
value that because you come at the
position of oh it's killing a person we
don't want to kill a person that's a bad
thing right no no no human well-being is
much broader than just laws about murder
yeah no I'm saying that's one of the
things where it's not if you track it
all the way back it can be at the end of
the day it is very not conducive to
human well-being for us to kill each
other or in your or or in your view the
killing like the innocent child all the
language that you put on so it's like
being murdered is not condusive to one
so I think that in if we're talking
about abortion you can stop there and
say it's wrong to kill therefore this is
not it's not always wrong to kill yeah
and I I I can take yeah and I can take
that and I can say it's not always wrong
to kill and I think that and I think
that yeah yeah which is why abortion is
not so it's always wrong to take
innocent human
life I don't think that that's okay
we're going to get into what innocence
is but I think that when it comes to the
case of abortion yeah when it comes to
the case of abortion I don't think that
you saying that oh this is murder or uh
this is killing or everything and that's
wrong I don't think that that's
necessarily a wrong take to have but I
can say I can say that when it comes to
human wellbeing and what we both agree
on human well-being is a positive that
we should shoot for I think the best way
for us to achieve human wellbeing is
allowing half of our population to have
bodily autonomy right but so we we
obviously disagree there so I'm I'm
saying it is conducive to well-being and
OB objectively morally good not to kill
babies in the womb you're saying it is
Michael I see your point and I respect
your opinion but I think that is it is
conducive to human flourishing and
well-being and perhaps even morally good
uh to allow for legal abortion those are
contradictory opinions only one of them
can no so yeah we're still agreeing on
the groundwork of well-being because at
the end of the day you're arguing
clearly not no you're AR yeah in my
opinion clearly not because I think
you're flat wrong but what we're saying
is the groundwork of what is best for
human well-being is still there and even
though you could say like oh well we're
disagreeing on this thing we don't
disagree that we're trying to operate
for human well-being that's where our
morals are grounded now the way we go
about it can take different routes and I
think you're objectively wrong because I
think that if you have half of the
population being a slave to their
biology meaning the millisecond that
there's a baby inside of them they're
there's no autonomy there's and no
autonomy you lose your autonomy when you
you lose your b a autonomy yes what are
you talking about if in your framework
met anybody who's ever been pregnant
what do you mean what do you think I
mean when I say lose your bodily
autonomy do you think I mean you can't
do you think that I mean you can't like
go to Kroger or something I mean that
you can't make that decision imp if we
make abortion illegal I'm saying you no
longer have control over the
developmental process that's happening
within your body and I don't and I think
that it's not conducive to human
well-being because when we're talking
about granting rights respecting
people's rights granting equal rights if
we say that a is a person deserves all
the equal rights of everybody I could
even agree and grant you that they do
deserve all the equal rights of
everybody right but one of those things
is not getting to use somebody's body
for life without consent oh well then we
have a contradiction so then we have to
figure out if that's really a right or
not is the is the right to abortion
really a right at all seem like you you
actually seem to have concluded that
it's not before reversing yourself and
saying it is because you've just said
that the baby I'm saying for the I'm
saying for the S sake of argument I can
grant you that the fetus is a person
with all human rights right but one of
those human rights that no one else gets
in any other circumstance isting to use
somebody's body against their will no
matter whether or not you put them in
that situation or otherwise you don't
get to be forcefully the government
shouldn't get to forcefully connect you
to somebody and then you cannot
disconnect from them well that's a right
that nobody else has you're trying to
give to you know how the baby ended up
there right yeah I know how the baby
ended up there and that's why we got to
get consent pregnancy was probably
because of an a willful action of the
mother and the father yeah it probably
was a willful action of the mother and
the father but if I if I have a kidney
disease running in my family and I know
that if I give birth or my wife gives
birth to a child there's a high
likelihood that they will have the same
kidney disease and then they're born and
they have that kidney disease and they
need a kidney does the government have
the right to force me to connect to
donate my kidney to keep them alive no
though it might be a good thing for you
to do but no the reason is because your
kidneys are for you they're for the
functioning of your body well therefore
the functioning of filtering blood no no
no you can say therefore you can say
they're for me in the same way that I
could say a woman's universe is for her
for her baby no it's for her no it can
facilitate you just made my point what
is so you you say the purpose of a
kidney is to filter blood right for you
for it's not my kidneys aren't for
filtering blood for you they're just for
for filtering my blood now they're for
filtering blood though so but they're my
kidneys right they're part of me they're
an integral part of me so uh my lungs
are for taking an oxygen uh my yeah it's
for taking an oxygen not your for you
for you because it's for you because
you're using it but so what is the if if
the end of the kidney is filtering blood
and if the end of the lungs is taking in
oxygen and if the end of the eyes is
seeing what is the end of the womb the
end of the womb or the end of the uterus
would be for procreation there you go
yeah yeah but that doesn't mean that
anything that happens to that thing is
now out of the jurisdiction because it
has the ability to Fester life so the
thing that I'm talking about is well
we're talk about blood cell we talk
about life those things technically are
alive they don't have the same I can
grant you they don't have the same Not a
Human Being yeah they're not a human
being cell of my hair but you can't say
that well no one else has a right to my
kidney because it's for me at the end of
the day a kidney is a kidney you can
write off about donating a kidney before
you die and then your kidney between
your kidney and my kidney which is
there's a distinction between your
kidney and my kidney I think that my
kidney is for me but again again when we
talk about it's not necessarily what
it's for and its utility the process the
thing that kidneys are for are donating
blood and and and you can say it's a not
donating blood for filter I'm sorry but
you can say that it's a moral good I
could say you're morally virtuous if
you're in that for if you're in that
situation and you decide to donate your
kidney I can say that that's a morally
good thing to do I would never legislate
that you must do that and just saying
disordered yeah but I'm saying if you're
just going to offer well no cuz it's for
me well it's like okay if we're
operating based off your framework work
it doesn't matter whether or not it's
for you you put your child in that
situation you knew that if you had sex
and you procreated chances are your
child was going to be born with a
debilitating uh kidney disease and as a
parent you have to take responsibility
for that and forcefully give them your
kidney no but this is a fallen world and
and everyone this a Fallen World
everyone endures some suffering so it's
not we don't uh you know Sue our parents
in a law court because of the inevitable
suffering that comes along with life
that that would that would seem rather
unusual yeah but that's just not
traditional suffering though it's kind
of analogous to to sex and pregnancy
because if I am having sex with a person
and I know that there is a nonzero even
a high probability that they will have
some defect or some like for the example
a kidney uh disorder and I know that
that's a possibility when I go into it
if we're saying that you know that
getting pregnant is a possibility when
you go into it therefore when the
pregnancy happens you are your uterus is
their possession now and you cannot
control not their possession but it does
what it's Natural end is I mean I think
we've arrived at something that's
important here which is that we know
what things are uh largely by what
they're for right that's the distinction
between like like if I I have a
microphone here let's say I had a bigger
microphone though I had like a you know
a rockstar
microphone and I you might ask me
Michael what is that in your hand I
would say well uh it's a microphone what
distinguishes this microphone in my hand
from some other similarly looking object
that I could I could hold in my hand for
instance I could use the microphone to
hang a painting on the wall right I
could use it and I could hammer a nail
into my wall and it would probably
Hammer the nail probably wouldn't do a
very good job at it but it would hammer
the nail it probably break the
microphone if I did that so I I could
use the microphone for that purpose but
it would it would be a better ordered it
would be a better use of the microphone
to use it for for amp would you out
would you outlaw using it for hammering
it into a wall well I not necessarily
but if it redounded in the murder of a
child I probably would oh see again
there's the intuition pump again because
now we're going to go back to the whole
it's not murder because it is lawful and
then you're going to say oh because the
the moral law that you subscribe to you
agre my moral law that is not murder no
but there can't again there be multiple
moral laws we're just disagreeing over
over the moral law yeah well you're say
well because we both we're not even
necessarily disagree we both arrived at
the conclusion of human wellbeing and
you just think that it is murder
therefore it is not human wellbeing and
I'm saying well no it is letting a woman
decide whether or not to carry a
pregnancy to term seeing as consent to
sex isn't consent to pregnancy and
consent to pregnancy isn't consent to
staying pregnant so I think giving them
that option is conducive to well-being
and you think it's not because it's
murder so the well-being part is still
there you're just using the I don't so
you you keep coming back to this phrase
well-being which is quite interesting
because it's it's a core aspect of uh
ethics going back at many years now
going back to the Nic mean ethics of
Aristotle and it's good we all want uh
human flourishing udonia is one way to
to uh call it but you you seem content
to just leave it at that and say well we
just disagree over the nature of
well-being but can't we dig in a little
bit deeper so if if we say that U
morality is objective and we are simply
perceiving it in different ways and
we're having a disagreement therefore
about the the true nature of what is
good for human beings then can't we
continue to interrogate that question so
I think you you arrived at it though you
tried to jump off it very quickly which
is you said the baby in the womb is
entitled to all the rights that
everybody else has well but I said but
the mother I said I'm going to Grant you
the argument that even if it is a person
it does not have if you're going to say
that it's a person therefore it is
endowed with all the rights of people
one of those rights is not to use
somebody's body against but well now so
now we arrive at this issue of a
contradiction but going also a
contradiction well because you just said
that the baby has a right to all the
right to to the same rights that we have
now one one of those would be the right
to life that would be the most basic
right but then you're what do you mean
by right to life the the right not to be
murdered let's say in this case the
right not to be murdered so let's
say is that that's all you mean when you
say the right to life in this instance
Yeah so basically okay again murder is a
spec okay so here I thought we here here
here here no cuz you can say that you
disagree with killing from a moral
standpoint in certain circumstances
that's completely fine the term murder
only means the legalistic one that we
have it doesn't mean that it's calling
to even in into question objective
morality because murder murder the
concept of murder is unlawful killing or
unjust killing of a of a innocent person
those are all things that we agree
morally are bad you shouldn't kill an
innocent person you shouldn't unjustly
kill somebody but that at the end of
that it is kill when you say murder is
calling on our moral intuition you're
taking a legal term that has specific
legal definitions and trying it trying
to apply it to a moral sense when all
you really mean is that you think it
should be murder let me try a different
tack here on the same question do you do
you think slavery is wrong yes
okay you think slavery in the American
context was wrong
yes do you think slavery is
unlawful yes today if I said back in the
day no it's not unlawful that' be a
statement of fact that's not me saying I
agree with the process with the ins so
why do you disagree why do I disag why
would you why would you if you were
living in 1860 in some regions of the
country why would you say that slavery
is wrong when when when it would also
have been lawful by your understanding
well again you can say that murder is
wrong but if I said that working for
somebody is slavery that would also be a
wrong statement you can say slavery is
wrong but I can't say this one aspect of
like working is
slavery so what I mean by that is if I
say that murder is wrong that's a true
statement cool but if I say abortion is
murder you're just trying to get it to
well therefore abortion is the reason
you have to prove that abortion is
murder the way you would make the way
you would argue that is you would say
that the baby in the womb that you're
calling a fetus
on top of that I'm sorry top of that we
don't even we don't merely legislate on
moral so even if you think that abortion
is immoral that is different from what
should be legal all all laws derive from
the moral law but that's cap but we'll
get to that that's a nice one this is
this is really important uh the argument
that abortion is murder rests on whether
or not the baby is a baby so I'm saying
the baby is a baby you're saying the
baby's not a baby in exactly the same
way that the Injustice of slavery rests
entirely upon whether or not the black
person is a person or not a person well
no because then it would be whether or
not the fetus is a person correct not a
baby but even then exactly wait I'm
sorry cuz I'm going to need you to
repeat what you said after but you you
you just casually slipped in there that
all law comes from the moral law right
because what is law so
question speed
limits do you have like a strict moral
position on like what a given speed
limit should be yes a a speed limit
would be arrived at uh as a as a matter
of prudence which is a cardinal virtue
for the well-being of the traveler and
also the safety of the people around him
okay so those would be moral
considerations so is driving 40 m hour
in a 35
immoral uh it's probably not too
imprudent it's probably not too Reckless
therefore not too unjust I wouldn't say
it's there's any moral value in driving
40 in a 35 and the reason why I say that
is well it's disob to the Civil
Authority when you go a certain
threshold over a speed limit say you're
going like 20 over and say it's a school
zone you can say that's a moral because
you're seriously endangering people
right but when you're talking about what
we have is law in our society driving 40
and a 35 will get you no moral
condemnation nor should it because
because there are different degrees of
stuff so you can't and then something
like still might be less morally
significant than criminally speeding in
a school zone but it would still have
the way you would arrive at the speed
limit would be through moral debate and
moral deliberation yeah you could talk
about moral debate and moral
deliberation for developing like the
threshold of of that's what I'm saying
the even if you take the uh the the
speed limit example and you can say okay
well at this threshold it's not immoral
and at this threshold it is
immoral yeah you could do that same
thing with anything with abortion but
you might be right or wrong some laws
some laws might be unjust
I'm sorry
like what do you mean by that I mean
like for instance when uh when the
abolitionists came around in the 19th
century they said it is legal according
to the positive civil law for uh white
men to enslave certain black men but
according to the higher law that is
deeply unjust wait hold on that's a
contradiction if all law comes from the
moral law then how did slavery becoming
legal even happen because this is a
fallen world and people use because this
is a fallen world and because people
have sometimes defective reason
defective will so they sometimes
legislate evil things no so when you say
when you say that law or all law comes
from the moral law moral law is
objective and then you say well slavery
was a legal process but you believe that
that's wrong now you're saying because
our reason and our Wills are
imperfect yeah but I'm saying you're
saying that if all law comes from moral
law right you could just be wrong about
abortion about your St on abortion
right so you're saying that abortion is
murder and murder is always wrong
because it comes from the objective
moral law but there are other things
that come from objective moral law that
we wouldn't say or we we should say in
its application no it doesn't because
how would slavery come from an objective
moral law because of the defect of the
intellect and the will of the people who
legislated it which is why after after
comparing the the clearly defective uh
positive law with the objective moral
law which we can use which we can do
through our conscience and our reason we
we realized that there was a mismatch
here and that the Civil positive law was
unjust that's why we got so you're
saying the natural state of like our
having moral law is that slavery is
wrong but it's our reasoning that that
twisted and made it so it was correct no
it's that this is a Fallen World with
defects in our intellect do you mean by
Fallen world I mean it's not perfect
was it ever perfect well before the fall
yeah so that's a religious concept yeah
but what is
religion religion is a certain subsect
of beliefs T tending to be in theology
when it comes to what is theology I mean
theology is the study of gods the study
ofing understanding is sometimes what
it's called and religion is a habit of
virtue that inclines the will to render
to God that which he deserves well
that's again your opinion you can say
that it's a habit you can say that
religion is a habit of virtue and I can
list off a bunch of different ways
religion has been used in a non-
virtuous fashion well right but but I'm
saying one of in the text of certain
religious books nonmoral you said that
what I've done you said what I've done
is just explain the Fallen World in
religious terms and then you've
criticized my definite religion because
it takes into account reason why I'm
saying is that if there is an objective
moral law that everybody that everybody
knows that everybody know it perfectly
that's the problem because our wills and
our intellects are defective as a result
of the fall of Man okay so you're saying
that there is an objective moral law
that is dictated To Us by a god of some
sort yeah and it's knowable through
reason yeah and it's knowable but we've
been fallen and therefore we don't know
the moral law without substanti we we we
we do have a a reasonable degree of
certainty about certain things we if you
get 100 people in the room at least 99
of them are going to agree that murder
is wrong but we don't have possess
perfect intellect and perfect will the
thing is the reason why I don't
subscribe to that is because there is no
demonstration there is no substantiating
that this that any of that even happened
that led to a fallen moral world and
that's why we're here today I think what
do you mean by that when I say that
there's no demonstration I mean
religious is religion is a unfalsifiable
concept and that you can you have it's
falsify you can you could try you could
try to make an argument fify because we
have no way of even measuring a
supernatural phenomenon because we have
no way to even develop a criteria by
which we we measure super we we can know
there are for instance you can believe
well but I guess this gets back to what
we were talking about earlier right I
can believe and I can think things and I
can have opinions that are my perception
of reality and they can be more or less
correct but when it comes to religion
say the question is does God exist or
does God not exist and uh it seems to me
there are many very good Arguments for
the existence of God seem to me that
there are many many very good arguments
against the exist I've never seen a good
one you've well that doesn't mean there
aren't any I gu I just I thought I've
I've looked for them I haven't found
them I'm not sure how confident I am
that you've looked for them I've seen
some of your stuff re years I've seen
some of your stuff reacting to certain
people how you like portray their
argument off I again and it's completely
fine to to uh Voice or um frame an
argument in a particular way if it goes
against something that you deeply hold
but the reason why I don't develop I
don't understand what you mean by that
do you think it's fine for me to you're
saying that I've I've of you that you
find wrong but you think it's fine for
me wrong I'm saying that I I think that
it's like you're I won't say fine I said
I think that it's understandable which I
should say that you would couch certain
arguments yeah but no but uh that You'
couch certain arguments that like
disagree with your religion in a
negative light or whatever because I
don't think that you've genuinely
honestly gone and searched some good
Arguments for and against religion JJ I
was an atheist for 10 years I was a
pretty Harden atheist for like 10 years
I I I I was uh quite taken with people
like um you know uh Richard Dawkins
Daniel Dennett Christopher Hitchens Sam
Harris and and more serious atheists too
like bertr Russell one of the great
logicians of the 20th century uh and I
believe that your reasoning in this
Fallen world has been clouded because it
clearly was because I was taken by the
aist after you went back or after you
went away from atheism that's a whole
other but it's pretty important because
you know uh ultimately these questions
are going to rest on uh ultimately
they're going to come down to whether or
not God exists because uh really basic
aspects of how we're even speaking here
will come down to that how is it it can
come down to that but again you have no
way of demonstrating that a God exists
that you know that there are many good
Arguments for God there's many good
arguments you have no demonstration of
whether or not a God exist what their
moral code is if your God is the correct
God if your God is the only option over
other yeah according to you but I happen
to be correct yeah according to you so
again what I'm saying is if we're going
to Der derive our sense of morality from
an unfalsifiable claim which again you
did do in our video when you said that
consenting to being in a bar is by
default consenting to being drunk
because near instances of sin which is
the near occasion of sin this is this is
a really important point the near
occasion of sin because it gets to what
we're talking about which is that in a
fallen world we have defects of our
intellect and our will so we're not
perfectly free all the time but think
about Hunter Biden uh we'll get to the
morality of Hunter Biden you know
sleeping with the 50th hooker of the
week uh how did Hunter Biden come to
sleep with the 50th hooker of the week
and film himself doing it well he
probably went on a long bender and he
probably drank a lot and he probably
smoked a little bit of crack and he was
probably half out of his mind by the
time he called up the hooker and then
slept with the hooker at what point
would you say he consented to those
sorts of Acts um I don't really believe
in adequate consent when you're under
the influence um but bingo so I want to
continue that in one second first though
when you want to protect your data
you've got to go to
expressvpn.com
slm YT as you know there are a lot of
people who want to look at what you are
doing online the government the isps the
big tech companies they all are digging
into your stuff and so you should use
the number one rated VPN on the market
not just according to me but according
to a number of outlets and authorities
as well that would be
expressvpn head on over there right now
we've got all sorts of great deals and
promos if you are a listener and a
viewer of this show do not wait well
actually you can wait you can wait until
the end of my conversation with JJ but
then you got to go immediately over to
expressvpn letter y letter T that is
expressvpn.com
slm YT today head on over there
momentarily
after I finish this point with JJ as we
were saying I don't really believe in
consenting when you're properly Under
the Influence Bingo that that's great so
why not uh because I don't believe that
you are fully within your I want say
like within your mind because if you're
doing all the stuff that Hunter Biden
has allegedly done then you're probably
out of your mind but you're not fully in
a state which in which you can give
consent you're not in full command of
your intellect and your will is what
you're which is all any of your
faculties or any of your faculties right
right probably your bladder probably at
that point too so that is that is a
great description of the near occasion
of sin which is that uh we can do things
that compromise our will and our
intellect and lead us more into
temptation such that by the time that
we're ready to call up that hooker on
the hunter Biden hotline we've already
we've already so compromised our will
and our intellect that we
we we have very little control over
ourselves that's insane and the reason
why you just said it no but the reason
why it's insane no I didn't say the part
about oh by the time we have so little
control of ourselves that being in a bar
that being in a bar means that you're if
they can't consent then how is the act
of Simply being in a bar yeah I know
what I'm saying if they can't consent
then how is it that they are consenting
by simply being in a bar what you said
in the video was that because of the uh
near occasion of sin you by the time you
go to the bar and it's a and it's a
Friday night or whatever you're
beginning the process of consenting to
being drunk for me it's not that
dangerous because I'm not an alcoholic
for all my many sins that's not not one
of mine uh but as as I pointed out I
think in that video if someone were a
drunk if someone were an alcoholic
inclined kind of person then to go to
the bar on the one hand doesn't doesn't
seem like you're consenting to getting
drunk but if you know that you are so
inclined then if by putting yourself
around all those delicious cing bottles
and all those drunken people you are
more inclined to take the first drink
and once you take the first drink you'll
be more inclined to take the second
drink and by the time you take the
second and third and fourth drink you'll
be more ined if you took yeah more
inclined is not the same thing as
consent if you take the first drink that
doesn't mean people are granted to come
up to you and give you more drinks if
you're in the bar and you're an
alcoholic and no one really knows that
you're an alcoholic that doesn't mean
that people are permitted to come up and
just give you alcohol regardless or
force you to drink it because you did
not consent it doesn't matter what you
think you are tending to do based on
your preconception or your predilection
of uh maybe I'm alcohol like maybe I'm
at this bar unless you drink and you are
physically doing that you aren't
consenting when I said that you can't
consent sometimes because you're in that
state of mind that means that even if he
were to be drunk say you went and uh did
a you drunk a bunch or whatever and then
you wanted to have sex with somebody
right even if they say yes I do it's not
consenting because you're not in the
right State of Mind trying to say oh
because you're not in the right State of
Mind you not even doing the action means
well I just can't control myself which
means the same thing as consent it's not
some some people can't what I'm doing is
just taking the principle that you've
agreed to and taking it to its logical
conclusion no you're not because the
principle that I agree to is that if
you're under the influence you cannot
consent you're saying that because you
might have a predection to being under
the influence what you do is not
necessarily governed by consent because
you have a predilection to do things
that take you out of the influence I'm
saying if I'm saying if Hunter Biden
drunk a bunch right and he did a bunch
of drugs right and then some girl wanted
to have sex with him he said yes I in my
book that still doesn't count as consent
because he has no governing over his
faculty so now and I'm also saying that
if he was sober and he said I didn't
want to have sex or or I do want to have
sex and someone else said no they also
that is not consenting so I'm saying
consent is both revocable and it's not
something that you can give if you're
under the influence so if you were to go
to a bar and you get alcohol anyway or
whatever
because you know I'm alcoholic and me
being here means I'm more likely to
drink unless you drink you still haven't
consented to being drunk I I guess then
my question is
does is booze or crack cocaine is that
the only thing that can compromise our
will and our intellect and kind of it
doesn't matter what comprent compromise
say other things could too like if
you're a sex addict you know and you go
to a br that could comp that could
compromise it too any number of things
if you're a big fat Glutton and you're
around a bunch of cupcakes that that
could that could take you out of your
mind too put you in a cupcake filled
ecstasy so so the point is that there
the the concept of the near temptation
of sin is that Temptation can uh uh
increase and that we can do things that
more or less incline us to fall further
into temptation and more or less
compromise our Wills which I think you
what you're saying is a slippery slope
argument you're saying because we can do
things that can compromise our will that
means we could do something else that
compromis our will which means you could
end up sitting down at that bar which
means you could drink which means that
the first part when you walked in the
door that means you're already
consenting to being drunk that is a
logical leap that is phenomenal world
record for that long it mean it means
that you're consenting to the
possibility and the increased likelihood
that you want to Dr not that you
inevitably would but that you're yeah I
wouldn't even in the in the bar analogy
it's so dumb because I wouldn't even say
that you're consenting to the
possibility cuz you could go to a bar
and just not drink you're not an
alcoholic I'm not an alcoholic
alcoholics have a hard time going to
bars and not drinking yeah I mean cool
but that again does not that does not
further your argument because it's
applicable in one situation where
someone might have a predilection and
even then they still haven't that's the
instance I'm desing yeah okay so then
you're saying that show the broader
point of the nearas no but you can't you
can't draw that to the broader Point
you're saying because an alcoholic might
have a higher predilection to being
drunk when they come into a bar even
though they haven't drunk yet
they're saying being in the bar for them
in particular is essentially yeah much
more tempting it's not consent though
you said much you said consent oh it's
yes you consenting to that great
increased Temptation so you're
consenting to a possibility but you're
not consenting to being drunk yes you're
consist you're consing to the possib
point no but you were saying beforehand
and then you you therefore incur some
culpability for it by placing yourself
in the Iration of sin so by being in a
bar okay so again I don't think you
understand what what consent is
but what do you think consent is so
consent is giving the okay being willing
to to partake in an action not only just
saying yes but also being enthusiastic
not saying that you have to be like yes
I'm so ready but like having a having a
will about it where you're like I want
to actually actively participate in this
thing so if you're telling me that the
process of being in a bar in itself
means that you're consenting to and keep
in mind because if we're going to draw
this back to pregnany keep in mind we're
drawing this back to pregnancy so it's
not just like this one outcome cuz you
could consent to sex but you couldn't
you don't have to consent to a
relationship or you don't have to
consent to like engaging with each other
past that point you consent to sex if
you're saying that that means you're
consenting to every possible outcome of
why then you're saying being in a bar is
being in a bar so again what is the
problem if you're in a bar and someone
comes and shoves tequila down your
throat so you're saying consent is a
matter of willing right that's what you
just said partially yes okay so like and
so how does one will
will
presupposes thought right intellect if
you're consciously willing something
enthusiastically consenting then you are
reasoning about that thing and
determining is this going to be good for
me bad for me true false whatever right
okay so to consent you need to have
reasonably solid faculties of will which
presupposes a reasonably solid faculty
of if you don't have reasonably solid
faculties then it's not consent that's
the thing so if you're in a bar and you
don't have reason you don't have uh your
faculties about you you drinking or you
being in the bar still isn't consenting
and when when we are in the proximity of
sin when we're in the throws of lust or
gluttony or whatever well first of all
again I don't want to bring us all the
way back to a met meta ethical
conversation but you would need to even
substantiate that sin is a real thing
that exists and that is your and it's
the sin that you believe in it's the
actions that you believe in that are sin
and not any other religions you need to
deduce that via reason and evidence and
then after you establish that could you
only then say that being in near
instance of sin is but you you don't
even make that logical do do you think
that some things are better or worse
than other things yeah okay so then we
agree that there is such a thing
morality as morality and there's such a
thing as virtue and there's such a thing
as morality there's such a thing as
virtue but if you're telling me that and
sin yeah but if no because if you're
telling me that wearing mixed Fabrics is
is a sin well I can disagree with you
there I don't think it might be a sorial
sin but it's not a moral sin do you know
what sin is I mean that's a commandment
what you mean it's sorial sin don't wear
mixed Fabrics yeah oh well uh to
understand the Christian religion one
needs to understand it in the light of
the Incarnation and the crucifixion the
Resurrection the history of the church
which is the The Rock on which our Lord
built his church against which the Gates
of Hell will not Prevail so there there
are certain ritual laws of the Old
Testament na nation of Israel there are
certain moral laws there are right so
there different different kinds of laws
that are prescribed in uh the books of
the Bible uh which is could be a long
conversation in itself but you've just
said that there's good and bad and so
therefore there has to be sin because
sin is is merely privation of the good
that what you think I I don't think that
sin exists that's my thing I don't think
that yeah I think there's good and bad
do you think that something could be
deprived of good what do you mean by
deprived would something be
bad yes things can be good then you
agree that sin exists that do mean that
sin exists well that's that's the
definition again you can say it's yeah
because sin is a specific religious
concept so if you're saying that bad
exists con I'm saying there are many
things that are bad that aren't sin if
there's if I'm walking next if I'm
walking next to somebody and there's
they're in a wheelchair and there's a
ramp right and I could go up the stairs
that's right next to him but I choose to
run in front of them and go up the ramp
that's not a sin I can look at someone
who does that and be like there's the
your Able Body the the the stairs are
right there you didn't have to cut the
person in line and go run up the ramp
and they obviously need the ramp to be
used right now you could have walked up
the stairs that's not
sin that's just a bad thing if I if I
lie sinful to injure a disabled person
how is that injuring I said walking up
the stairs in front of no you cut them
off yeah that's what you're said that
yeah I don't mean cut them off as in
like push them out the way I'm just
saying like you yeah you just cut around
them go up the stair and you didn't you
didn't you didn't need to go up the ramp
you're not inconveniencing them you just
said you're not injuring them at all
yeah what do you mean by in you mean
physical injure or do you mean like like
tor lawp injure where it's like any any
like damages mean to harm them in any
way you know inconveniencing them for
their meeting or yeah I could say that
it would be an inconvenience to them and
I could also like put my moral thing on
it again like legality morality that's
all other thing I don't think it should
be illegal for people who are Able Body
you to walk up the ramp but I can say
morally that's not my most favorite
action you could have walked up the
stairs just fine but you chose to cut in
front of this person who needs the ramp
now to put yourself ahead of them when
you had a whole other option that
wouldn't even get in their way so I can
say that's bad but that's not a sin and
sin is dictated by religious Creed and
it's set out specifically in
Christianity with the various things
that are sins but that doesn't mean that
everyone else is or that doesn't mean
that there's things that you can't do
that are bad that aren't sins or things
that we can consider good that may white
after Labor Day that would be bad but
it's not a sin but it's like I don't
think that I don't think that when we
say that something is sin um or or a
near occasion of sin therefore means
that you're consenting to being drunk by
being in a bar that's a logical leap
that you would need to even prove that
sin exists first and by you trying to
prove it by saying well good and bad
exists that doesn't mean that your
religious concept of sin exists you
would need to substantiate that first
well right sin or religion rather is as
I said just giving God what he deserves
that's what religion most religion is
the thing that presupposes that God is a
thing that you can give what certainly
also presupposes that God exists yeah
but so no so that's what I'm saying it's
you can't say that you can't Define
religion as giving God what what he will
but that's that's the whole thing you're
kind of sneaking the definition in
without substanti no yes religions uh
Orient themselves toward God that's true
so if you're system that orients itself
towards a God or or tries to uh theorize
about God or Gods yeah it just yeah it
acknowledges that God exists yeah well
no it belief it's a belief that God does
exist see
true I know I know that you see what I
mean there because I know you're a smart
guy so I know that like your rhetorical
strategies are are can Beyond point but
the thing is if you're why do you think
they're on point I think it's on point
because a lot of people who are watching
this who don't really who might not like
me or might not be they like or maybe
maybe they do but a lot of them who
might not be too versed on like
rhetorical strategies can see because
they believe it's like yeah it's just
acknowledging that God Rel persuasive in
this case perhaps because it's well
reasoned no it's not at all I think it's
because of the way that
if you would let me explain why I think
it's on point I think because when you
just said right there you said it's uh
acknowledging that God exists right yeah
that's because it's a common sense
statement to you and to your audience if
you say religion is acknowledging that
God exists that of course they're going
to say yeah because I believe that God
exists and if you're religious you
acknowledge that God exists but you kind
of leaped past which is why it's not
reasonable or sound you leap past the
part where wait do we really know that a
God exists and if we do how do we
demonstrate well here's how we
demonstrate uh things are in motion
right we're in motion you and I are in
motion the Earth is in motion the stars
are in motion the galaxies are in motion
uh uh things in motion do not put
themselves into motion so I like for
instance if I had a ball here I could
take this ball and I could throw it at
another ball on that desk over there
well and then that ball this ball that
was moving that I threw would hit the
other ball and that ball would fall down
on the ground it would roll and that
ball would maybe roll over I don't know
another little tiny ball on the ground
and it would keep you would see things
continue to move as a consequence of
those actions so we can go back and you
say well Michael how did you start
moving and I'll tell you I started
moving because my mother and father
loved each other one night and they
created me and how did that and you can
go back through all of these uh actions
that caused movement But ultimately
you're going to have to come to an
unmoved mover who is God or no you could
actually so it could be an unmoved mover
it could be that there's a finite amount
it reduces by finite amounts the amount
of movement so in that ball analogy when
you throw the ball and it hits another
ball it would be slowly slowing down
because of the force of friction so it
could be something that was moving or
maybe has the potential to be mov that
just hasn't been actualized yet it
doesn't need to be an unmovable mover
and if it is I'm not saying at I'm
saying the unmoved Mover is at the
beginning yeah I'm saying yeah it
doesn't yeah I'm saying the beginning
doesn't need to be an unmoved mover and
if it is bring and if we're if it is and
we're bringing it back to a a god
perspective then if God is the same
today tomorrow always and is the unmoved
Mover then what does prayer do think
about it if God is changing their mind
about something not changing their mind
but say I call to say I pray to God say
I pray to God about something right I
want him to fulfill something for me I
want him to uh make my water into wine
right here let's say that I pray to God
for that he'd have to do something that
he wasn't doing already in order to make
that happen you have to answer my prayer
correct but God God if God were to exist
God would be the creator of all things
mhm by definition yeah so God would
create not only space but time mhm right
so God would necessarily be outside of
space and outside of time oh he wouldn't
necessarily he could again we're talking
the maker of all things then he made
time no well I mean if he's the maker of
all things he could make time but he
could also make himself subject to time
because again this the power of a God
we're talking about we're operating on
the framework that as we understand time
the thing that has to create time has to
be outside of it but like I was
God does enter into time in the
Incarnation you've arrived at an
important distinction between before we
before we get to the distinction I want
to press down on the fact that if God
has created this water right here this
water currently is not wine doesn't
matter at which point he decides to make
it wine he has to decide to make it wine
that is in a sense in in in a sense the
unmoved Mover moving because you have to
be in a state of mind to okay I made
this this is water I now want this to be
wine that is you making a decision you
are changing your mind about
that's the cas then God has to be a
moved M because you cannot say that oh
well you know what he's just a unmoved
mover but I'm going to pray to him and
he's going to do something for me that
he hasn't already done because he has to
change something about himself in order
to do that thing well our lives unfold
in history and the the way to understand
God's relationship to history is through
a concept of Providence uh Christianity
is especially an historical
understanding of God because God takes
on human flesh in the Incarnation then
lives for 33 years and then is crucified
and then on the third day rises again
from the dead and then he's on Earth for
40 days and then he ascends up into
heaven and sends the Holy Spirit to his
church which is the visible expression
of God's kingdom here on Earth so I'm
with you in God's role in history but
the the error you've made is that you uh
have forced God to be subject to time
before God made time no I'm saying but
again this is assuming that he did any
of those things but I'm saying how do
you know that he couldn't have made
himself subject to that time how do we
know that is without how do we know that
it's outside of the possibility of a God
to both create time create himself in
the time how do we know that one has how
do we know that one has to prede another
for operating on the framework of God
because the creator has to prede the
created yeah but SP SpaceTime created
it's part of the physical creation well
does it have to again we're talking
about God here if I create something I
have to pred that thing if God creates
something we don't know what God can do
we're here talking about abortion and
life and everything in our aspect
apparently there are angels and
everything that are subject to a
completely different realm when it comes
to life and how they perceive it subject
to God's sovereignty no I no I'm saying
yeah I mean of course but I'm saying
that um we for all we know life could be
created on in a billion different ways
it doesn't even just have to be the way
we came about if we have angels we have
other things up in a different realm in
heaven that's lifee don't get into the
aliens no no I'm saying that's life but
it's it's subject to a completely
different subsector rule so we're saying
the way we internalize it is well
obviously something has to proceed this
other thing has to proceed this other
thing has to proceed this other thing
that not only is does not have to be the
case with a god even if that is the case
all it could imply is that there could
be various things it could gradually
decrease it doesn't have to be a a
singularity it could be a a string of
things that are kind of gradually going
about it doesn't even have to it could
be an infinite develop in history it
could be an infinite regress for all we
care we don't know it can't be that how
why can't it not because there has to be
an unmoved mover or I'll give you let
let's say if this if this so if that's
if it's if we're looking at change right
if we're talking about an unmoved mover
or whatever how is it that change is
just conceptualized as just something
preceding after another right we could
change could be a change in color a
change in property of something right we
could say that something created
something or whatever and it wasn't even
NE just a progression of it it just kind
of shifted in color or it gradually
decreases or anything any of the above
possibilities cuz we're talking about a
God here for you to assume that because
one thing must cause another must cause
another must cause another and we can't
have I'm just saying it yeah they right
they the happened now just by definition
has followed the thing that immediately
preceded it yeah right in our world yes
so I'm saying if we're working within
the scope of of a God we have no idea
what laws or or or we do because we're
made in the image and likeness of God
that's how we can well but so so you
can't say that well I know this property
about God and God definitely has this
property because I'm made in the image
of God and this is how it works but
you're presupposing that that God even
exists in how do you know anything how
do I know anything um I usually analyze
like uh I I think the basis for knowing
things is subject to uh evidence so
basically when I say I know that I'm
like here right it's not like I pulled
out a bunch of dictionaries and I'm like
what is the definition of here it's we
it's a known fact about the world that
people exist and I'm exper consci huh
because we can see that we can observe
how do you know that what you're seeing
is real and not just a hallucination
that's a big question I don't think you
truly can know that I think I can know
whether but you're very confident in
your opinions I think but you just said
you're not confident that I'm also
confident in the things that I don't
know I think it's confidence being able
to say when you don't know a thing I
think that but what you've just said is
you don't know for certain that you know
anything at all yeah I don't think you
can know anything for certain I'm I'm
reasonably certain that you cannot know
anything everything for certain well of
course not but but but I'm not asking if
you can know everything I'm asking you
can know anything anything for certain
you can know it to a degree of certainty
I think you can get infinitely close to
like that 100 you can get 99.999 depend
how can you get that close how can you
get that CL
evidence how do you know that you can
rely on the evidence that you're seeing
well I think that knowing that I can
rely on the evidence that I'm seeing I
can always like see evidence that leads
me astray but it's a process of like
mental reasoning that you can see
various things that lead up or that uh
give good warrant to believing a certain
proposition that doesn't by default mean
that that proposition is true if you're
going to go for the brain in a vet it
could all be a simulation we genuinely
don't have an answer to that question
I'm not saying I'm not even asking that
I'm asking well that's kind of what
you're asking it isn't how do you know
that you you can rely on your faculty of
reason to communicate to you the truth
because I think that how how do you know
that your your reason is Dependable if I
think my reason is Dependable or I know
my reason is Dependable because of
things like evidence it's so when I look
at when I'm when I'm analyzing yeah so
I'm saying when you're building your
reason right why would you have reason
to believe something well I know the the
things that I have to operate within me
right now I know that I have articles
that I can read about abortion I know I
can I have studies and everything I can
further back than that yeah I'm saying I
can say that like oh well I don't know
this for certain again that can track
back to literally everything maybe I'm
not asking the question properly I'm I'm
not asking how you have an opinion about
abortion I'm asking how
you trust that any opinion you reach
that any perception you have about
anything is reliable and has some
accordance with reality so that's the
again that's the brain in the vat
question because what what you're saying
is how do you even so if I say um I
think that that cup has or this cup has
water in it and you're saying well how
do you know that and I'm like well we
know that water exists we have the
molecular makeup whatever and you're
like well how do you know you can rely
on molecular makeup I'm like well
there's a science there's a field of
scientists that have broken down the the
composition of water and you're like how
do you no but I'm saying and you're
saying well how do you know that you can
even rely on that and it's like well
truthfully I don't think you can know
anything for
100% but you can you can work within the
framework that you're operating right
it's an a that you're just beginning
with so what you're beginning with is
precisely where I begin which is that
you are made in the image and likeness
of God and the defining feure about you
is your reason so you're saying that the
only you think it means the only way so
wait okay wait so and it's funny because
this argument doesn't even support
theism because you could be created in
the image in a likeness of a God but
what's to say that that God is the
reason for why you have reason what do
you think the phrase being made in the
image and likeness of God means
literally whatever people who believe in
a god want it to mean it Christians even
disagree about this in the same way it
could be oh well we're just we are just
like God we can be co-eternal with God
if we take the right steps or it could
be there's Christian Science no it's not
Christian Scientists it's a o I forgot
what the religious Domin denomination of
Christianity is but they do actually
believe that they have like a is it
Mormons they have a father mother God
and they believe that each of them can
can become like God but they can never
Excel to the level of God that's just
their personal belief what what what
would it mean to what would it mean it's
funny well I don't the thing is I don't
know what that you don't know the answer
so the answer is I don't believe it so
okay but you can you you can know things
about things that you don't so whatever
properties whatever properties you what
I think that being made in the image of
likeness of God is is whatever
properties you attribute to that God you
guys share similar prop it's not a trick
question actually that that no that's
what I'm that's what my answer is it's
whatever there's a more specific answer
which is our intellect and our will our
reason that that is what that is answer
believe is the case because you could
very well believe no you could very well
believe in your God and people who
believe in a different God than you
could believe could believe that being
made in the image of them is a
completely subset different subset of
categories and attributes that we
attribute to ourselves again you would
need to demonstrate that yours is the
one and only correct one first before
you base your Axiom off of all that
because you're just working off a big
assumption no matter how deeply you
believe it at the end of the day it is
one big assumption and at least I can
show you progress and steps to where I
can
you you just said that you have to
assume that your reason is reliable you
have to take that merely as an
assumption as a premise to start with
you can you can test that if I can if I
come up with various conclusions say if
we wanted to know something say if we
wanted to know what water is right and
if we came up with a criteria by which
we measure that and the chemical
composition and everything right and we
see we studi the the water cycle we
study everything that has to do with
water and we come up with a very we come
up with predictions on okay well given
these circumstances water should act
like this if we got all our properties
down and we reasoned through this and we
knew this correctly we're able to know
something correctly then given that
water should act like this in this given
circumstances we have yet to be wrong
about that I don't know if water can
just go from freezing to just like
vanish in an instant it could but we
have no demonstration of that all we
have is a pattern of research and and
understanding to this point that shows
that we're able to make predictions and
see this is actually how this is working
so with that in mind we can say okay
this is fairly reasonable we can rely on
this if we were just looking at it as
like oh water's clear which means it
must be have some property of becoming
invisible well it we can say oh yeah
well I I think that that's the case but
if it continuously gets proven wrong and
it never happens then that's not a
reason but you're you're if you're going
to ask me how do we know that patterns
are reasonable well or or how do you
know I mean to use the example that you
like coming back to how do you know that
you're not just uh you know living in a
video game or something again that would
be an assumption it's just a premise
I don't know if I would I don't know if
like I think that I wouldn't call it an
assumption or I wouldn't call it a
premise or anything because I don't
genuinely think that you can know that
but you live as though you're I don't
think that you I don't think you live as
though things are significant I don't
think that even if your brain was in a
vet I don't think that that means that
the things we're experiencing aren't
significant that's one of the things
that gets back to God I think if we
living even without a God I don't think
that that means that everything isn't
significant but you live as though your
faculties of Reason are are dependable
and that you're not being perpetually
deceived well yeah and
deceived how do you determine you're not
being perpet deceived I think you're
lying if you don't realize that it's
analyzing the things that are at your
disposal and making predictions and
analyzing you yeah you have to take it
you have to if you're going to if you're
going to say because we 100% don't know
for certain that everything around us is
a figment of our imagination therefore
we're operating on faith and that faith
is the same Faith as this God who
apparently has told you everything you
need to do and could never be wrong
despite the fact that everyone else
believes in different God that's not
quite what I'm saying but it's close to
draw
that what I'm saying is that what what
I'm saying is that there are many
different modes of inquiry a
philosophical deliberation scientific
inquiry and all number of manner of
inquiry uh but they all have to begin
with intuitive reasoning and with the
Assumption of premises in the same way
that mathematics has to begin with a
with a set of assumptions a plus b
equals B plus a you can't prove that but
those are the the those are some of the
you can prove that once you test it if
you if I say if I say
say yeah if I say 2 + 2 equal 4 right
again the the we can say that the the
number system that we developed for it
is like a figment of language but the
principle if you have two objects and
you add two more objects and you count
but I'm saying even more atically you
have to begin with 3 + 2 equal 2+ 3 for
instance yeah so if we did that then we
could we could run experiments or test
to make sure this formula applies in
every scenario we shouldn't get 3 + 2 =
1 plus seven we shouldn't get that at
any given point if our things are
working correctly let me see if I if we
continue to get these same answers and
we continue to not be proven wrong in
these same things you can know with a
higher degree of certainty whether or
not you're correct about that if you can
know anything all you could never know
for sure that everything around you is a
figment but even if everything is around
you is a figment you still know things
within that figment and it's not
necessarily like the same leap leap of
you just don't know it but you could be
deceived at any you wouldn't necessarily
rely on say continuity that the world
you're living in today is the same world
was that existed my thing is that you
can't know that either you say you can
I'm just I'm just I'm just beginning
with certain and using my reason based
on those premises yeah and if we're
going to if we're going to begin with
certain premises and everything what
would be more of being deceived Us in
reality all being brains and Vats but
not only do I I'm comfortable with
saying I don't know that for certain but
here's these things I can work with
whereas you say well no we're not a
brain in a vet I know this story and
this story is the one true story and
everyone else's stories are wrong while
yeah greatest story you ever told so
it's like which one it would be more of
a level of Deceit you could say that the
one is true would would be the one
that's true would be the true no no the
one that's the one that's real and true
would be the Real and True one and the
one that's a deceit would be the deceit
but even so say say like truth is say
the truth is that our brains are in aat
and we can never necessarily obtain that
truth right because we don't really have
a way of proving that we're not in the
vet I feel like my position of okay
here's what we're working at let's try
to make these observ see where it gets
us okay this is leading here okay maybe
we can predict this maybe we can predict
that I think using that method of
reasoning is infinitely more likely to
get you closer to the truth of the
matter that being we find something that
determines oh it must be a simulation as
opposed to the belief system of okay
well I believe in this deity and this is
how this deity is telling me to act and
you trying to make those equivalents in
in leaps because we can't for sure know
that's I think we're we're missing the
point a little so let me try we're we're
way off the point I want to get back
but but on this point uh to use a
popular question can a man become a
woman that's a that's a weird question
to ask it's a weird question kind of
weird that we have to ask it isn't it oh
no because genders and different
societies have always been fluid and
have always worked so it's like when
when you ask can a man become a woman
it's like well a person can become
whatever they want but it's like if
you're subscribing to the category of
man then you unless you stop subscribing
to that category a person a person can't
become whatever he wants a person can't
become a seagull for instance oh so we
can't become what yeah because we have
to stick within our species yes I
understand that we can't physically
become a seagull but so I'm saying can
one SE become the opposite man and woman
is not objective in the fact that a SM
and a a seagull and a human is those are
completely different yeah and one we're
talking about differences in species and
one we're talking about differences in
Sexes so my question is can one sex
become the the opposite sex can one sex
become no can a man become a woman can
an individual man become an individual
woman yeah if they were identifying as a
man first and then they said nah I'm
going to shift up and I want to become a
woman then yes they can but like the
category of man you mean how how can
that man become so when it comes to sex
and when it comes to gender and
everything there are many different
biological processes that go into
determining one's sex and then
corresponding with that gender could be
biologically male and their testicles
could like grow inside of them and they
would they because cuz there's a I
forgot what the specific Gene is but it
like doesn't bind to a specific receptor
and it doesn't release the right hormone
so you end up developing the same body
as they have a deformity well not the
same body you've got test no yeah as in
like everything that from an outside
perspective looking at everything that
we'd associate with being a woman
broader hips uh breasts every like all
the physical attributes you could
develop allal attributes yeah well I
mean obviously outside of like a uterus
or something but like and even then
there are women who don't but anyway
besides the point you could develop all
those things that would classify anyone
in any other circumstance as a woman
they're not you just admitted they're
like the the central essential things
you're not developing is your genitalia
the central essential thing that's the
differentiator so what gender or what
sex are so inter sex people are real
correct well uh people have genital
deformities and certain chromos you say
when you say genital genital deformities
that's kind of like just described you
know but you're kind of assuming that
that's like it's a defect because it I
wouldn't say necessarily it's a defect
because again our genes and our hormones
have all types of we are all born with
like the same like not same possibility
of becoming a man or a woman or a boy or
a girl because you don't get born a man
or a woman but like you're born with
that same genetic code where if a
receptor doesn't buy into a receptor or
if it does or if you have a xxy or or
whatever you that significantly shifts
what your outward Pres presentation is
going to be so if we're talking about
what someone's gender is or what
someone's sex is there's always been
variation in humans especially the
categories that we there the categories
that we assign to those variations we
can draw box around it but us drawing
boxes around it is just trying to best
understand to our ability but if there
are people who are clearly fitting
outside of those boxes there is nothing
wrong than just redrawing the Box we
always do that all the time sure some
people have deformities that's true and
we we even though they can usually
pretty clearly classified like if you
have testicles you're probably a man but
you just said something different if you
have testicles you're a male yeah but
the category of man is something that we
ascribe to the people who are
traditionally male that's what I'm
saying so when a male human yeah adult
well a man would be it can be like again
a man corresponds to the category of
male human adult but it's not is that
thing there are more things than just
being a male human adult that makes you
a man if I were to go on Like Jesse Lee
Peterson show and I'm talking to him
about how I like respect women or
something he could call me a beta a beta
male I'm less of a male he wouldn't call
you a woman huh he could call me womanly
he's called people on multiple occasions
he said he's he's no I'm pretty sure he
would call me a woman because he
womanish he wouldn't think you're an
actual woman he has a lot of things
going on so he could probably call me
womanly woman all of the above he think
a man who behaves in an femin he thinks
that people who are liberal are women or
womenly anyway so he could call me all
of the above the point being that the
category of man is much more than just
what chromosomal makeup you have even in
a society where you can say oh that's
acting womanly there are societies that
have existed prior to us and that
currently exists today where roles are
flipped men will stay home and take care
of children uh women will go and kill
and hunt and everything that's been most
hunter gatherer societies have been
intensely egalitarian we have this
notion that it's always been the big
strong man going out to that's not even
like a a realistic expectation because
if your big strong man is always the one
going out to hunt there means there
always the most likely one to die and
then you die out with that strategy and
as opposed if you all work together
which is why we're such a social species
that's been established so you would
send the women the weaker sex out to
hunt there's societies that do that all
the time I I is the thing what do you
mean there aren't really have you have
you read anything in anthropology yeah
yeah and what book told you that there
that there aren't really Societies in
which they there were the mythical
Amazon in a few examples I'm pretty sure
you can go on PBS um and which to that
are in which the women go out oh for the
life of me we studied um multiple tribes
in what is it it's like it's subsaharan
Africa I know it's Southern is it in
Ghana I forgot exactly what the name of
the tribes were we had a whole chapter
on in my anthropology course where we
talked about um conceptions of gender
and and uh sexuality throughout
different cultures and there's uh I
can't remember the name and it's going
to eat me alive but there are groups in
which the women will will hunt like and
do the tackle and everything they they
do this they have another thing called
um it's kind of like self-de
self-deprivation where like if someone
goes out and gets a kill they won't brag
about it if they brag about it then the
other people will like joke back at them
but in a fierce way to like humility
yeah but like it's it's not even like
you imposing your own humility it's like
they will humble you if they feel like
you're because they all feel like that's
the right yeah a lot of things that we
do will are are correct or fit for our
society because we believe that it is
that way but that's not to say that
there aren't Societies in which people
work together even in our society is a
lot moreal than principle because we
women can't just afford to sit at home
and not work anymore as much as they
used to we're all kind of working
together to provide that income and
children get a better um society and a
better life that way I'm not sure
they're getting a better Society and
also someone else to take care of the
way so usually what happens is the woman
goes out to work and then make some
money and then pay some other woman to
raise the kid at daycare so it's not
like you've actually fixed that problem
you've just changed the way the economy
works assumtion look it is someone's got
to raise the kids yeah well I mean yeah
both it could be a man if men and women
are both at work then who's raising the
kid yeah I'm saying they both share time
or you could get a and even then it
doesn't necessarily need to be a woman
Tak taking care of the kids the reason
why it is a woman is because we've
socially assigned the role of caregiver
to women and of worker to men despite
them both being capable of doing either
job which is what other societies have
seen which is why both of them do you
just can't name them right now oh no I
can't no
can again but again I want to I I like
the chuckle and it is fun but like if
you genuinely do care about the issue
you can go look up gender diversity
within within species or gender
diversity human societ literally Google
gender diversity within human societies
and just because they're Amazon why do
you keep saying because that's the the
mythical tribe of female warriors so
that doesn't even that doesn't even need
to no it's not female warriors is not
what I'm saying I'm saying egalitarian
societies I'm pretty sure I thought you
said the women go out and fight yeah I'm
saying there are some societies where
the women do that but there's also more
Societies in which it's more an equal
thing even since we were Caven it's more
of equal thing so getting back to what
we were just discussing for since you
grant that a man can become a woman then
getting back to even what we were
previously talking about how would that
man know that he is a woman and how
would you know that that man that's a
completely that's a completely
societally formed thing so the way I
would know that somebody who's a male is
or doesn't want to be a man anymore they
want to be a woman I'd know by things
like how they outwardly present things
like the type of societal roles they
want to ascribe to over a different one
sometimes there's nothing there's no
rule saying women must have long hair
but whenever people think of a woman
they usually think of somebody with long
hair so if you want to subscribe to that
role a step people will take would be to
grow out their hair or something doesn't
mean that they need to do it but that's
just something that we kind of assume is
womenly despite the fact that there are
many men with long hair there are
certain roles that you can pick and you
can choose and you're like thought you
said the roles don't matter and they're
all just sort of socially assigned just
because they're socially assigned
doesn't mean it doesn't matter race has
no root in biology but the impacts of
race are still felt what do you mean
race has no root in bi biology I mean
that it has no root in biology there's
greater geneal genealogical differences
between members of a given race and
members of completely different races
black people in the United States are
the most diverse race when it comes to
genealogical perspective because we live
in a society where race is based on
Ancestry so if your great great
grandpappy was black you technically
could be classified as black depending
on how you present despite the fact that
I'm way darker than that person you're
black and I'm at least vaguely white a
little Sicilian but I would be
identified as white no one would be
confused about that fact even even if I
took on all the cultural attributes
stereotypically associated with black
people and you did that for white people
that's the conflation thing is that
because two subjects are socially
constructed does not mean that they're
socially constructed in the same way
there's not really like attributes that
you could take on as a black person that
would make people confused about whether
or not you're black because the
conceptual the the concept of being
black is specific phenotypes that are
dependent on Heritage and then also like
you're talking about like your hair is
different than my hair yeah like my your
bone structure is different than my bone
structure not even bone structure
necessarily because it's not that much
variation in bone structure at least in
African-Americans in the United States
but I'm saying between between different
races yeah but the reason why no one the
reason why no one would confuse you for
being black and no one would confuse me
for being white and everything is
because the way we conceptualize race in
today Society is well this category what
I look like certain attributes that I
have classify as your body yeah that's
biological yeah no your body is your
body is formed through biological
process but the value and the terms and
the boxes we draw are not biological so
in the in Rome in ancient Rome it was
either you were a Roman or you were a
barbarian if you were a member of Roman
society if you were a Roman citizen or
whatever you were considered a Roman
they had different skin colors in Rome
but that doesn't mean that they
didn't as race they saw that their race
was Roman and every other race was
Barbarian there is no they didn't say oh
I'm black Roman I'm Brown Roman I'm
white Roman those are boxes that we've
drawn in American society why do you
think that isn't true why do you think
how well there's a good book came out in
2006 on racism in ancient Greece and
ancient Rome it's by Benjamin Isaac who
is a Princeton historian and classicist
and he points out that the concepts of
race and even racial hostility were
extraordinarily present in the ancient
Roman and ancient Greek worlds and it
goes back much earlier than that
actually it goes back to like the
Egyptian Book of gates which was written
roughly 3,500 years ago in the Egyptian
Book of gates you you see a discussion
of different races of people not merely
cultural differences what the races so
that's my thing Libyan uh Nubian
Egyptian I forget the but I'm saying no
no this was 3500 years yeah I'm saying
I'm saying race as we conceptualize it
in this Society yeah there can be other
races in like ancient Society but their
racial categories were not what our
racial categories are and even then I'm
not going to dispute what the word of
the historian is right now I'm going to
look it up after I guarantee you
probably misrepresenting it but assuming
that you're not I'm going to be
charitable and assume that you're not
yeah when we talk about race in ancient
times a lot of times at least from the
scholarship that I've seen it's things
they'll talk about like eye color and
they BL hair color but they wouldn't
like refer to it as we are one United
race and you are because an Empire
conquered all that territory so even
even from a logistical standpoint it's
physically impossible for them to have
the the racial categories that we did
today often times they still had racial
categories though this was true through
the Middle Ages too it's just a it's a
myth there's a myth pushed by liberals
uh especially in this one book that was
written by some random oped journalist
uh the new Jim Crow that suggested that
race is a a creation of the last couple
hundred years by white people in the
United States it is the reason why is
because the thesis goes even more
ambitious than that and says as you've
been saying that Antiquity didn't have
conceptions of racial differences but
that's not true and through the Middle
Ages it's true you see even the Muslims
no they had no what I'm saying is they
had conceptualization of racial
differences but the concept of race are
completely different depending on
society so in ROM times you could
probably get away with being confused as
being a Roman because they are very
specific things they weren't even like
very specific things but if they
considered you a barbarian it was an
outsider somebody who isn't like us you
could slip into a given society and
assimilate enough to where it's like
people could confuse you as a Roman but
they'll never confuse you as black and
me as white because in America the
categories we have drawn is skin color
and and certain phenotypical features
despite the fact that we have gender and
we have a genetic diversity across
gender I mean cross R the thing is those
categories have always existed if you
that doesn't mean that they're
biologically rooted because a group of
people is born with blue eyes does not
mean that the blue eyes is a a thing
that must be assigned value out of some
biological reason we assign value to it
out of some I'm I'm not saying anything
about value at all I'm just I'm just
saying that you're that's how the racial
category is but you're making you're
making a historical point that in
Antiquity through the Middle Ages people
did not conceive of race based on these
biological or phenotypical character I'm
saying race is not biologically rooted I
didn't say that there were no racial
differences but I said like in Rome
Roman was their race Barbarian were
other I'm saying that's not true and
because I cited for instance no but what
you cited was them saying there were
racial differences and racial
hostilities and think yeah again but
that does not I said there were but
there it varies depending you were
saying you were saying there was no
other than between Roman and Barbarian
saying that isn't true I can I can grant
the point that there are probably other
distinctions besides just Roman and
Barbarian but I'm saying while there are
racial differences throughout history
the racial categories that we draw are
societally based there is nothing
inherent about black people that make
them more likely to have negative
stereotypes there's nothing inherent
about white people that make them more
likely to be a dominant group in society
there's nothing inherent about the skin
color of of various Asian people even
though that's not even consistent
because we just classify them as Asian
that makes them have whatever values we
assign to Asian people those are boxes
that we drew perfect example is Irish
people Irish people in the early 1900s
and late 1800s were not considered white
they were pushed into the same that's
not a disputable that's not even
disputable they were that's not even
disputable Michel they were
discriminated against and they weren't
considered white you would have a better
argument if you pointed to the southern
Italians uh for instance the largest
mass lynching in American history was
against Italians in New Orleans you
might say that in certain parts of the
South they were considered lumped in as
black rather than as white even that is
kind of overstated That's Not Over based
on based on American history I mean
listen I I've I've sure looked at and
researched a lot of American history and
uh um Irish people were not considered
then specific in the same racial
category as white people they were from
English there's a certain thing even if
you go to Irish uh if you go to Ireland
now there's a thing called Black Irish
right and that doesn't mean that they're
actual black people they just like are
Irish people with like slight it's like
a slightly Tanner white but it's like
even just that just being of a different
uh nationality that wasn't considered
conducive to broader white American
culture deemed you as not being white in
the same way that Barack Obama is in the
same way that Barack Obama is equally as
white as he is black but he's considered
black right yeah he he didn't run as
Barry sooro which is which is the name
he went by for much his life he went as
Barack Hussein Obama because he thought
that would give him an electoral
Advantage well I mean it probably has
something to do with both his dad on his
African side doing that but I don't
think he just changed but he went by a
different name he went by Barry his
nickname was Barry in his childhood I I
think think he's always been named
Barack no but he didn't he didn't
present himself that way even Joshua
William Joseph I go by JJ if I said I'm
going to go by Joshua Joseph on the
ballot that doesn't mean I'm trying to
I'm deserting my name and I'm going with
that name to get me electoral advantage
that's just my government name look po
politicians do this his government name
wasn't Barry is what I'm telling you
that's what's his nickname sure so so
why did he go by a different name for
much because he's running for I'm not
going to run for president as JJ that's
a colloquial term that people who are
close to me refer to me as if you want
to know who I am Teddy Kennedy ran for
ran for office as Teddy Kennedy Mitt
Romney ran office Willard Mitt Romney
ran as as Willard yeah I'm saying Ted
Kennedy ran as he ran brother wait are
we talking about RFK Jr or are we
talking about Teddy Teddy Kennedy was
you oh yeah that was I forgot that was
another candidate and his brother was
Robert again but that doesn't
necessarily mean that like there's an
electoral advantage in him getting I
don't think in 2008 America it's an
electoral advantage to go by Barack the
only reason anybody 7 years after 911
we're talking about I think the only
reason people voted for Obama is because
he was uh an impressive speaker and
because they could say they voted for
the first black president I don't think
he had any accomplishments other than
that any whoa any accomplishments at all
you mean prior to becoming president or
I think that he was a a fresh new face
he was what did he do he didn't
accomplish anything before he was
president well I mean well he was a
senator from Illinois he was what did he
do what did he accomplish as state
senator from ill well as a US senator
and before that I'm not sure what I know
he was uh very outspoken against the
Iraq War I don't know what his what he
introduced in the senate in 2006 the
answer is nothing I'm going to take you
at your face value and just say okay he
didn't even then I don't think that
Barack Hussein Obama is the thing that
would give him the Electoral Advantage I
think people voted for him yeah in part
because he was a black president or he
would be a first black president but a
lot of people also voted against him
because he was going to be the first
black president that won he won a huge
portion of the American a clear majority
I'm pretty sure he yeah he won a
majority of the electric but what were
the racial breakdowns I'm pretty I'm
pretty sure 56 or I'm pretty sure 56 to
60% of white people voted against you
know8 or 12 huh in in the first round in
the second round I know he I know he
lost the white vote by a big by not a
big margin by like a pretty substantial
margin in the because he was a terrorist
no both both times white people weren't
like swooned over by by Obama and then
in 2012 they were like oh this guy's
trash they thought he was trash the
entire time white people also tend to
vote for Republicans yeah much more
likely to vote for Republicans than
Democrats yeah no but I'm talking even
white Democrats like a lot of them it
wasn't it's not like I'm pretty sure
Obama won a majority of the white
Democrat vote but if you're talking
about the entire nation as a whole I
agree that white Democrats are racist I
agree I certainly agree with that but we
G agree that everybody racist now what
what you well I agree that some white
Democrats are racist I agree that the
vast majority of white Republicans are
racist though really yeah what makes you
say that oh yeah oh yeah you think
America is a racist
country it's really hard to say no and
the reason why is because how racism has
been baked into so many of our
institutions I wouldn't say I think
there's a difference between saying I
feel like when people say is America a
racist country they're trying to add the
like the moral prora that it's like well
he thinks everyone is I'm say America a
racist I think the way in which America
has been founded and operated like yeah
I think so today it's a racist country
oh yeah how many vages how many black
people have immigrated to the us over
the last 20 years I'm not sure about 3
million 2 million from Africa and a
million from the why would they come to
America if America was so racist great
question that is a real great question
why do you think a lot of Muslim people
and a lot of people from the Middle East
still come to America despite the fact
that they were literally profiled and
targeted all after a terrorist attack
that really had nothing to do with them
in particular I don't remember any anti
as people come to the United
States they face very fair and Equitable
treatment that's why Asian Exclusion Act
Chinese Exclusion Act asian bar Zone oh
well you're talking Japanese interment
camps what fair and Equitable treatment
are we talking about I I'm sorry I
thought we were talking about no I'm
saying I'm saying but you're saying why
would they come here they come here now
because obviously America's gotten
better no one argues that America hasn't
gotten better you say if it's racist if
if America is actually hostile and
discriminatory against black people why
would three come in in 20 years well
first of all if we want to talk about
black people who immigrate here yeah um
often times they come here with I'm not
going to say they come here with a
preconception about African-Americans
here but there's a demographical
difference between black people from
Africa who come here or from other
countries that come here and from
African-Americans that are actually
already here so a lot of them will
immigrate here from backgrounds of uh or
coming over for college or maybe they
already had a family member from a
wealthier background that is sending
them over for college that makes up a
lot of um especially a lot of work visas
will go to Nigerians and Indians because
they're working in Tech Industries and
stuff so it's not like these people are
and because in general maybe wherever
they're coming from The Economic
Opportunity is probably better in
comparison to their country that doesn't
mean that they did a holistic review of
the race relations to the United States
and determined this country isn't racist
anymore I'm going to take my chance over
there they thought about it before they
immigrated I don't think that it's a you
think they thought is a good idea to
move across the world to this evil
racist country or you don't think that
that that that that passed through their
mind because a I think that a country
can have done evil racist things in the
past and you you're saying today it's
still racist I think it's still racist
yeah there you go yeah but I don't think
that that's a determining factor in the
so you're saying that if I go there
there's an increased likelihood that
I'll face discrimination cool but if I
go there I could also get a job that's
going to make me way more money than
over here even if I'm being
discriminated against at all and in fact
we know that it's much uh you're much
more likely to get a job today for a big
company if you are identifying as a
person of color rather than as a white
person when yeah so okay so one of my
favorite studies in in sociology is when
they'll do application studies and
they'll um change up things like uh
maybe they'll provide a picture or
they'll do names right since
1985 there has not been any change in
the likelihood of getting a call back
for a job when you are black and
according to the sociological studies
according to Scientific consensus in
sociology this is now let me let me
raise another Prospect to you there was
a study just came out an analysis by
Bloomberg of 88 companies in the S&P 100
and it was it was over uh hiring
practices over the last few years
because the EEOC the Equal Employment
Opportunity uh commission uh requires
that big companies with with more than
100 employees publish their work
Workforce demographics and over the last
couple of years 94% of people who have
been hired for a job for any of those
companies have been persons of color
which is pretty crazy because the
country is 60% white which means the
only way they could have arrived at that
number is by actively discriminating
against white applicants and giving an
advantage to persons of col I'm going to
assume that I can't even assume that
your numbers are 100% correct CU are
they can you're going to trust me that
I'm going to look it up and it's going
to say that 94% of people hired for a
job at these few corporations not few
it's 88 of the top of the S&P 100
they're talking about the biggest
companies in America we're talk we're
saying that the the workforce 94% of the
new hires yeah 94% of the new hires how
many new hires uh so because you do
understand that you could have a high
proportion of new hires be hired as
minorities and the overall makeup of the
company can still be white we're talking
about the the policies in place today
talking so so 88 of the top 100
companies are attempting to increase
their diversity by hiring higher rates
of minorities and that means that the
racism's gone no it means that there is
new racism against white applicants if
only
6% why why would they why would they
need to hire because we have we have de
facto and de Ure racial discrimination
and employment against white people and
to a lesser degree against there's deao
racism you know what deao racism means
or deao discrimination yeah what does it
mean so deure racism would be as a
matter of explicit law and de facto
would be as a matter of implicit
practice and in the case of affirmative
action policies it's actually both well
actually no well the facto would be as
the facto would be so the way I like to
think about it is when we had uh when we
look at Public Schools today there's
still a lot of deao segregation left
over from the Jim Crow era because there
was no Ser because students
self-segregate yeah well because they
were put in a condition in which they
were already mostly segregated so you
can't there's even in mix schools I'm
saying there have been a lot of studies
on this and it's very odd CU because a
lot of people want don't don't like
there to be self-segregation but it
happens yeah it will happen because of
different like cultural backgrounds and
everything but that is compounded with
the fact that there was never a real um
ability to fully desegregate public
schools and federal busing with the
National Guard what yeah and they and
they struck that down that was and it's
funny because Joe Biden back at it again
he was opposed to the uh the forced
busting and everything along with a lot
of White America at the time and in 2007
chief justice Roberts they had the uh
Supreme Court decision where they
decided that attempts to desegregate
public schools by trying to by assigning
kids to schools based on like racial
background to try to like create a more
even mixture was unconstitutional so
even when we were trying it it gets
struck down and it gets struck down so
you still have not a properly addressed
situation which is going to if you're
spending all your life around people
around the same skin color of you then
when you get in the area even though
there are more people of different
colors you're probably going to be more
comfortable with these people around you
and that's due to circumstances that was
not I'm not I'm not disputing the fact
that there that there when I was talking
about deao segregation and the reason
why is because it's it's vestages that
are left over from policies that used to
be in place and not a serious act to to
correct them so how in the world is
hiring majority minorities in recent
years at corporations % how is it
virtually de facto segregation when the
whole reason why they're doing say say
racial discrimination how is that deao
discrimination based off of the when
well when the vast majority of the
people at the corporation a still be
white and be the whole reason why
they're doing that is to correct for the
fact well you might say you might say
it's good discrimination which I suppose
is what you are saying but it just is
nevertheless I wouldn't say it's I
wouldn't say it is good or bad
discrimination because I don't again
assuming that the new hires are are
really 94% uh minority applicants um I
think that you could say that it's it's
a discrimination in a sense because
they're attempting to correct us you're
saying it's a good thing it's
discrimination but again I'm just
telling you it it it it undermines the
argument that you're making which is
that America today is racist against but
you do understand that if you but you do
understand that if okay whoa cuz first
let me say you do understand that even
if you did hire at a 60% clip for white
people because they that's proportionate
right
you don't but saying you said it was
crazy
because yeah I mean if you can perhap
white people stop being able to do any
jobs 6% is 60% minority uh issue or is
it just because it's 94 when's the
threshold I don't I don't think that we
should have racial quotas for
hiring is it a illegal the that is
illegal so it's not a quota you can you
can a compelling State interest to do
like have diversity but there's not
saying you need to have X amount of
black people x amount of white people X
that's not so as a as a matter of the
Ure policy we have affirmative action
which is a kind of racial discrimination
against white people into to a lesser
degree Asians and as a matter of de
facto hiring policy we have clear racial
discrimination because affirmative
action I'm sorry how is affirmative
action discrimination because you're
giving preference to One race over
another so if you're discriminate let's
say let's say that well again and it's
not even affirmative action isn't even
necessarily saying that you need to to
choose one person over the other it's
taking giving an advantage no but one r
or another I wouldn't say that because
again we're talking about we're talking
about Advantage right how how is it that
an advantage is provided to a group of
people when they are given more
opportunity to actually succeed at a
level that's more proportional to what
they should have been doing otherwise so
if you put a bunch of institutional
barriers right and you say you cannot
come here because of race right you're
making an arbitrary decision or you're
cuz I'm saying back when College chines
Exclusion Act say yeah something like
something like that right if you then
proceed policies if you then put in
place policies to say okay these people
make up a certain subsect of our
population they live in the
society they should be participating and
we just decided that they're not going
to participate because of the color of
their skin then if we say all right
let's give more opportunity to them now
do you see the problem if you were to
then cry discrimination again because
then what is the alternative if we just
stop H having racial anything no
consideration of race right it's the the
the fallacy of colorblind law is that
what's the fallacy as in no law is truly
colorblind if you're talking about so if
we're saying okay we're not going to
have anything racial in it right we're
just going to hire um according to
proportion of the population which again
you're going to have no I'm not
suggesting that though I'm saying
we so not only by by factors of sheer
math are you going to have way more
white applicants you are neglecting the
fact that the reason why you have so few
minority Aints isn't just because
they're applying at a proportionate rate
and you're just saying no because you're
being discriminatory they aren't even
getting the tools to get there in the
first place because of policy that
affected them in the past talk why they
at a disadvantage why are they at a
disadvantage we can talk about black
people in particular we can talk about
um redlining and housing discrimination
we can talk about um the we can talk
about the after effects of slavery and
debt ponage that no one talks about I
noticed that uh that I never see you
guys like cover daily wire cover like
anything when it comes to the history of
black people that accurately un like
explains where we are at today because
the last cadow slave released in America
was actually in 1942 and that's not like
a that's not like a crackpot Theory
that's because um right after
segregation or right after slavery the
South didn't kind of just like give up
and be like oh you got our slaves our
economy is just going to go along now
they attempted to have a system in which
they reimplemented it there over 9
million slaves around going around today
not in the United States yeah that has
nothing to do with what I'm talking
about so how how does it not cuz we're
not talking about the historical or the
we're not talking about the context of
people who are Liv slavery conditions
around the world I'm tell you slavery is
practiced everywhere around the world
today what does that mean it means
forced servitude yeah no I'm no I'm not
saying what a slavery mean what does it
mean that it's practice in multiple
places and everywhere today does that
mean it's okay no it's very bad but what
I'm saying we're basically the only guys
that ever stopped it in all of human
history we in the west yeah that's funny
what do you mean by we in the west I
mean Europe and the uh countries that
came out of the European colonies are
the only part of civilization ever that
decided to end the practice of slavery
and they did so for explicitly Christian
where do you think that slavery was most
popular uh well uh it was the Muslim
Pirates who were some of the largest no
that's the that's the she when it comes
to the trade of the barbar the Barbary
slave trade no not no yeah I'm talking
about that uh the barbar Pirates that's
in sheer number- wise like compared to
the transatlantic slave TR with
African-Americans in particular it's a
bigger number but I'm saying where do
you think it was most popular you're
taking that one instance today or no I'm
talking about historically you're taking
that one instance of slave trading and
you're neglecting all the sler that was
going on in Western countries if you
count up that number that's
significantly than the bar slaves I'm
saying even like slavery today for
instance in uh Africa is still practiced
there's a candidate for the president of
South Sudan who himself was a slave and
has been speaking out about the problem
of slavery all around the world at the
height of the transatlantic slave trade
there were more slaves who were held in
Africa than were shipped over to the to
the new world so I'm saying this and
this has been true in East Asia been
true in the Middle East and this is this
because you're failing to to draw a
distinction between what slavery we're
talking about these societies did have
slavery and that again has nothing to do
with American history but when we look
at a lot to do with extreme slavery no
I'm talking about around the world the
fact that every Other Nation or other
nations practice has nothing to do with
context so does America if you if you
look up any study if you look up any
source that tells you how many slaves
there are in the world they'll say
there's like 7 million in Africa and
they'll give you a number about 400,000
to a million in America based on sex
slavery sex people being held by the
cels on the open
border yeah in the in the United States
literally in our country because because
for instance like our Southern border is
open and so the cartels our Southern
border is open y we have we have uh over
three million people a year come into
the country illegally so it's open does
that mean that it's open effectively
yeah if you can't stop three million
people from crossing your border you
probably PR open do you have anything to
compare that to number-wise yeah so even
even uh five years ago uh the number was
down to about 2,000 people a day which
at that an alltime high is it 3 million
a year I'm genuinely concerned because I
I believe that it was around one um it's
not it's much higher than that um but we
have we have a million legal migrants
who come in per year which is also a
shockingly high number completely out of
accord with uh any other country on
Earth and any other time in history but
we also have many more millions of
illegal aliens Crossing into the Border
per year is a is a nice like uh term but
I'm saying like AAL foreign
National that doesn't mean that you have
to use alien kind of like alien just
means a foreign National oh I mean no I
mean in the ter if you're using like a
legal alien and you want to try to like
that that's like a i I want to say like
incorrect cuz I know you guys get about
like speech and like I know you guys get
but it's not like the term alien is kind
of like I know you talk I know you
talked about I'm not calling them ET I
know you know I'm talking I know when
you talked to Bronte you mentioned how
using the term fetus is like
dehumanizing I think using the literal
word alien is also dehumanizing but you
know alien doesn't refer to martians
alien refers to those who are not like
us of a different means Foreigner
they're foreign so they're subject to
foreign governments and they're here
illegally so we say illegal alien
you could also no a more precise term
would be illegal immigrant because they
went through the immigration process
illegally you don't have to say they
didn't go through any immigration
process that's immigrated somewhere
they're distinct from legal immigrants
that's just say a foreign National but
they're not you know someone in guatemal
foral but someone who's here who cross
their border illegally and stays in the
country be an illegal alien quick lesson
about like like um like grammar and
connotation right so like the term
blacks by our definition of what a
racial category is it is not incorrect
to call somebody a black but it is
technically incorrect to call somebody a
black because we like that's kind of
that's a word that's kind of been used
to because you don't like the word what
about whites that's also weird term it's
like segregation era terminology that's
why I don't use whites I don't use
blacks you can say black people or white
people but if you were to look at
someone crookedly after they said oh
blacks no one would be like oh well it's
just the correct term because yeah terms
can just like the word colored is a
correct term your skin color has color
in it white people don't really have
color it's funny cuz now the term is
person of color like people of color but
the but you don't I don't like that one
either I think it's very silly I don't
like that yeah because I think you can
be more specific but the broader point
that the illegal alien thing is like you
know that the connotation of alien is
like think you can you can you can give
me the dictionary definition you know I
agree with you that it has a negative
connotation the reason it has a negative
connotation is because it is a bad thing
thing to cross illegally into a country
they've done a bad thing and that's why
it a bad Reas why is it really a bad
thing to cross illegally into another
country yes it's illegal and unjust how
it's unjust to cross into another
country so it's funny because we're
going to get back on morals if someone
was like running from the cartel and
they had like it was a family it was
like uh little some little girls some a
couple boys with them and it was a
family that running across the border to
escape from the cartel but that that's
not what happens they actually you work
with the cartels to cross the border
illegally because the cartels control
the entirety of the Southern border yeah
OPP and the cartels run rampant within
the countries as well so if you're
trying to escape the cartel and the only
way you can do that you don't escape it
by Crossing illegally across that border
you have to work with the cartels to
cross illegally across do you think
every illegal immigrant is working with
the cartel yes practically speaking yes
the cartels control the entirety of the
Southern border and so they do is they
pay off the cartels and then they end up
in a type of SL wa after cross over do
you think that they're still working
with the cartel or do they work with the
they owe them a lot of money they owe
them a lot all the illegal immigrants
owe them a lot of money and they're
working with the cartel yeah they they
can you substantiate that I can't that
that's how they end up in prostitution
which was how we got on this topic
because of modern-day sex slavery or
they end up running drugs or they end up
in other criminal Enterprises for the
cartel well first first who do you think
controls the Border firstly firstly um
do you think that prostitution is only a
thing that is brought into America
through the southern border no like
illegal like sex slavery do you think
that's only exclusively done by
non-americans no of course not so why do
we keep why do we keep like making this
assumption like okay I ask I I ask you
to substantiate that every illegal
immigrant that crosses the border is
nowel secretly working with the
cartel and open yeah so and it's funny
because doesn't even need to be cartel
they can just pay coyotes who are
trained at running people across with
cel
at times but that doesn't mean that the
people then work for the coyotes that
then work for the cartel you think the
cartels just let these people off the
hook out of the goodness of their heart
they F them across do you think that
they have do you think that the cartel
has a database of the 3 million illegal
immigrants that come across the American
think they keep do you think they they
keep they keep track of them they have
more tracking they have more tracking
capacity than the United States
government who lost people's parents
under Donald Trump when they locked them
in cage when they they did it's
literally an image uh so when it comes
to illegal aliens yes the car actually
are better at keeping track of people
but but two than the United States
government yeah because the US
government just releases them into the
country but because that's a an
intentional policy of Democrats I'm I'm
but but do you know what I'm confused at
like how your worldview ends up like on
it so it's an intentional policy of was
that kind of like Grace great
replacement esque he say what do you
mean by great replacement like the the
theory that um Democrats or political
people are like deliberately conspiring
to bring to import more people different
they say that they say that they're
doing that there was a a major study
that came out in 2004 that shaped the
political campaign even of Barack Obama
who described the Coalition of the
ascendant you've seen a columns like
this in the New York Times by Michelle
Goldberg about how the Democrats need to
import more foreign people and that will
help the Democratic I don't think
there's any source that you could find
me out there that says that the
Democratic party has said that they need
to import more foreign people if you're
saying that they they appeal more to the
values of of immigrants they would want
to want to I think on Border policy they
they favor much higher levels imigration
and amnesty for illegal yeah they favor
a lot more levels of immigration because
immigration helps the country that
doesn't mean that they're saying we how
does it help the country it raises rates
of crime it raises rates of program who
first generation immigrants commit way
less crime than native born population
that is that isn't true you want me to
look it up for you of illegal immigrants
huh yeah any immigrants illegal not any
not any any and IL the okay I can look
up illegal for you too okay that's good
there there are some good studies to
this effect uh Center for immigration
studies has some good ones out there
about how uh illegal aliens are
significantly more likely to uh be on
welfare programs when they come over
here and how illegal aliens are uh more
likely to commit crimes as well and this
is especially focused in the Border
towns uh in places like Texas and
Arizona and Southern California um
illegal well I know that you brought up
the the welfare issue something about
needing to something about fleeing
somewhere and you don't really have
anything left could end up putting you
on even then a lot of times you're
talking about political Asylum huh like
seeking like ear no Asylum is a
completely typ of process but I'm saying
if you're going to run away from your
country and come to another country
illegally a a lot of immigrants are
hesitant and even getting on that point
and B they still pay taxes to their
wages so I'm pretty sure there's there's
data that they I'm pretty sure that data
out there suggest that they actually pay
more into uh welfare that they actually
get back because they're not about being
like there's something about illegally
being in a country that's going to not
put you first in line to be under a
government assistance program in case
they you know find out that you're no
it's not true but you we this is why we
have the concept of sanctuary States and
Sanctuary cities this is why Gavin
Newsome in California says we're going
to be a sanctuary State this is why New
York said please bring all the
immigrants here until the immigrants
caused a lot of problems in those cities
so that that all happens and the
Democrats are pretty explicit about it
the Democrats are explicit about but
favoring High yeah higher levels a
higher level for the here yeah yeah so
am I favoring a higher level politically
advantageous but it's socially
destructive so there's a difference
between it's also bad for the people who
there's a difference between saying I
want more immigration in my I want more
immigrants in my country because uh I
want to we should appeal more to them
and they can help our country and they
we want amesty for them there's a
difference between saying that and
saying we are going to deliberately
import people to replace a white
population that's the great repace what
do you mean to rep like you're going to
shove it kill the white brown people
that you bring in the less they breed
they breed with the people in the
country and then the concept of
whiteness gets like more and more
deteriorated till there's not as many
white people that's the great
replacement yeah that's what I asked you
about you said well yeah the Democrats
are deliberately and you they're
deliberately flooding the country with
migrants that's true I mean but they
well by not enforcing their border polic
how are they not enforcing the Border
you Jo Biden allows 3 million people to
come into the country so then how many
did how many did Donald Trump allow
because Joe Biden's immigration policy
has been mostly similar to Donald Trump
the numbers are much lower under Trump
and the the numbers in the first months
of Trump's presidency illegal
immigration collapsed now at six months
out into the rest of Donald Trump's
Administration the numbers started to
jump back up again but the reason for
that is because the Democrats styed him
on building the border wall and styed
him on on Ice deporting illegal aliens
and made a big haloo about uh Donald
Trump putting families in cages cages
that were built by Barack Obama Barack
Obama did not build those cages he did
no he didn't there's a there's a
completely different process they
literally didn't that's literally just a
lie I mean I I think we can get away
with lying when you couch it when were
the cages built I'm not sure exactly
what year they were built they were not
built by Barack Obama well he didn't
physically build themra okay yeah I'm
saying that that the whole concept of
the cages being used to contain these
migrants by way I'm telling you when
they were built you tell me when they
were built you're just insistent that
I'm not right about I'm saying you say
that the cages were built by Barack
Obama first of all I have no evidence
that his administration constructed the
cages and even if they did construct the
cages they were not used as cages for
people you do understand that the whole
reason the whole reason why the
Democrats made a big H about containing
people in cages is because a bunch of
migrants were coming across the border
and then the Trump administration were
shoving them in cages there was no
distinction between whether or not they
were applying for Asylum which the UN
said that we violated international law
on that front you can roll your eyes
about international law but the process
because the process they're econom how
do you know that because we have we have
60 years of data migrants their majority
majority the economic migrant no yeah
you can say a lot of them are economic
migrants but you have no way of knowing
that if you stop them as soon as they
come across the border and throw them in
a cage the legal process that we agreed
to on a national front is when someone
is declaring asylum in a country they go
across that border go to the nearest
station and they declare their thing for
Asylum and then they get Refuge while we
await the process what do you think the
cages are though it's not like literally
a dog cage it's process it literally
looks like a dog cage and they had foil
blankets they L you can google pictures
of it you get sure they didn't throw
them in sure they didn't throw them in a
Rottweiler but they process center CU
there were millions of a processing
center what processing were they going
through they lost people's parents they
were sitting there there were disease
breaking out there was foil blankets
there was really child just died under
the Biden Administration in the same
issue but of course it the media never
made a big a big deal about it because
I'm saying well actually if you well I
mean if you've been paying attention
Biden has been having a lot of criticism
about how his immigration policy like I
said has not been that different I don't
I don't see the crying AOC photos like
we saw under Trump further more you want
you think ioc is supposed to go to the
border and take a separate picture under
every president about no I think it was
I think it was a cynical Ploy and she
wasn't even near the centers when she
did it she was she was outside of a
fence and posing for a picture but even
even beyond the the processing of these
people there there was a a survey that
came out from fusion and uh Amnesty
International reported in The Huffington
Post so we're talking about liberal
organizations what percentage of illegal
alien women and girls who cross that
border illegally do you think are raped
or sexually assaulted I'm not sure the
the number is between 60 and 80 % which
gets to exactly what we were talking
about uh when we were discussing the
cartels so this is a terrible um in 2018
the illegal immigrant criminal
conviction rate was 782 per 100,000
illegal immigrants
535 per 100,000 legal immigrants and
1,422 per the one per 100 native born
Americans that is double illegal
immigrants um According to which uh this
is according to the KO Institute study
well that's k it's a pro migration think
tank but what where where what is their
data set it's libertarian what what
where's their data set from well I guess
they they've conducted multiple studies
on the topic of immigration through i'
just be kind of curious to dig into
those data you can look it up this it's
not even just KO I can find you another
one there is no there is no data that
you will find out there that says that
illegal or legal immigrants commit more
crime Focus specifically on illegal here
and I think we illegal either illegal
does not commit un unless even if you
count the one crime of crossing the
border that's yeah but you still don't
get to the native born population of
course you would because then 100% of
illegal aliens would have committed a
crime but but to your point and this is
where some of these numbers get a little
fuzzy which is why the data are hard to
get here they're not convicted because
they're not processed because they're
operating outside of the the standards
of the law and they're doing that
because the political leadership in this
country wants to keep them that way
because they think it gives them
political
Advantage um I was looking at uh I'm
sorry I apologize that I didn't
necessarily hear everything that you
said because I was trying to look at the
uh Scientific American find you some
other data about the crime statistics I
didn't know they were immigration
experts over there at scientific America
you can analyze data they talk about uh
you can that's a that's a sociological
study if you're trying to analyze
behavior of people and the likelihood to
commit crime that's so look I have no
doubt that that uh leftwing and
libertarian groups want to make
Scientific American is a leftwing oh now
yeah yeah Scientific American I guess
iful then editorial bias it does I mean
I mean you could you could go in
Scientific American and you could take
issue with methodology or debunk it but
if you're just going to say well it's
left no I'm just saying it it hasn't it
does have an editorial perspective which
is leftwing but and and it's kind of
silly that well the editorial yeah yeah
an editorial perspective where it's like
what articles that you're talking about
on like given topics it could be but if
the data data then the data is I think
that that's kind of my point though is
the notion that Scientific American
would be publishing a study on US
immigration policy politics when you say
Scientific American do you think that
science of American is just like we put
a chemical in a beaker and then this is
what yeah well initially focused on
natural science noty is a science well
it's a it's a or social sciences are
like like when you talk about um when
you talk about statistics and uh how
those apply to by that standard all of
Poli obervational studies right huh by
that standard all of politics is a
science there are scientific elements to
politics but if we're if we're trying
lot of
stions you can use science so can
science to analy because politics is a
social system so you can look at how
people behave you want to determine the
likelihood that somebody votes for
candidate X over candidate y there are
things that you can measure you can do
observational studies trying to see um
you know this actually brings this full
circle even though I know I've kept you
longer than than we were supposed to
yeah I think I've been getting calls
from you have but but this actually does
bring us full circle which is back to
different modes of inquiry and knowing
things because we've arrived back at a
very politicized type of science which
is to use scientific and clinical jargon
to mask political priorities that that
derive from deeper first principles and
so I guess the question I'd leave you on
we've covered a wide range of topics
have I forgot how long it's been since
we talked about abortion so did I
convince you on anything no I thought I
along the way you agreed with me in a
few different no I no I didn't agree
with you I think what you're talking
about is when I said I'll grant you that
they that the fetus has human rights but
the point is no the point was for the
sake of argument a fetus has rights
according to everyone else but even if
they do the one right that they don't
have is the same right that no one else
has is the right to use somebody's body
without their consent so is there not so
that's special is there not a
contradiction there no between the right
to life and the right to an abortion no
because I think that if you're saying it
depends on what you mean the right to
life I think everyone has a right to
life but you don't have the right to
life at the expense of the body of a
person without their consent so you can
live uh you have the right to life like
you shouldn't be why do you why do you
have a right to life why do you have a
right to life I feel like I don't have
an accurate depiction of what you entail
by the right to life and it's saying the
right to you just said we have one
though yeah no I'm saying you can have a
right to life because I know you guys
say like well everyone has a right to
life you can have that however you want
to think about that as long as it's not
at the expense of another person's body
without their consent and that's
something that's cons you think the
right to life is derivative from some
other
right that some other right would come
before the right to life I don't think
any rights come before right I think
they're kind of coexistent you don't
have they're all identically uh you
don't have one about the it's kind of
like a system if I took away the right
to life well then you can't have bodily
autonomy cuz you die but if I take away
the right to bodily autonomy you still
could have the right to life no that's
like me saying like you're free or
whatever and I set you free into a
desert it's like yeah you're free to do
whatever you want but you have nothing
at your disposal you're probably going
to die very quickly so if I say that you
don't have the right to body autonomy
but you have the right to life well yeah
you have the right to life until someone
needs your body to use and then they're
plugged into you and yeah you're still
alive but what kind of life is that no
well those are distinct things right no
it's not aromy and life are not distinct
things no I'm saying I'm saying they're
as distinct things in the sense that
think but but I'm saying no I'm saying
that I can say that you have the right
to life you could still be alive but
what kind of quality of life are you
going to have if if we don't have
mothers are usually I'm saying if we
don't have I'm saying if we don't have
body autonomy as a rule and I say you
can have the right to life you just
can't have the right to body autonomy
well you can have the right to life I
could be walking around but if but if
the government comes to Knocking because
somebody needs my specific blood type
they can just abduct Me and use me as
their blood as their as their donor but
that's not a good quality life we
wouldn't say so you don't have one
without the others you have the right to
shoot heroin right now uh no I think so
you don't have bodily autonomy no
because again that's when you when
you're looking at heroin or something
like that the same reason why it's not
treated the same thing as marijuana
because heroin not only is an inherent
danger to yourself which is taking into
account someone's bi autonomy because
it's like yeah you have the right to
shoot up the heroin but in shooting up
the heroin you're probably going to be
killing yourself oring or other people
yeah but you would certainly be hurting
yourself yeah but it's not like like
something like marijuana I think you
should have the right to to smoke
marijuana because those two things are
completely different we're talking about
heroin so at so for heroin no marijuana
yes at least in the case of heroin you
are saying that it is perfectly fine for
the government to restrict my bodily
autonomy to stop me from doing something
that would harm me like heroin um yeah
and that in in now we have we have
limited bodily yes bodily autonomy has
limits I'm not saying it's an absolute
thing and the same thing I don't think
the right to life is an absolute thing
in the in the example of self-defense we
all agree that if you kill someone in
self-defense you are they don't
necessarily have the right to keep on
living if they're trying to kill you in
the same way that b autonomy you don't
have the right to like my my right to
bodily autonomy ends where your no
begins so so bodily autonomy is worth
circumscribing to stop you from shooting
heroin but not worth circumscribing to
to stop you from killing your own child
uh again if you say killing your own
child that ending the pregnancy ending
the pregnancy no because pregnancy is a
biological process that happens within a
given group of people and they shouldn't
be subjected to go through it at any
given point just because the
government's going to arrest you or
prosecute you otherwise okay all right
again consenting to pregnancy doesn't
mean you're consenting to staying
pregnant so if you it is your belief
that uh heroin heroin has more value
than your own child right yeah the right
to shoot heroin would be more valuable
than protect more conducive FL oh no
Michael and I know that you know that
but well yeah I think that's wrong I
appreciate the couching though like I
know that you know that that's not what
I meant but I think I think deep down
you know that's not true but but you had
errors of reasoning that have no because
again I think that everything has limits
I think that your right to life ends if
you're trying to aggress on another
person and you're trying to kill them
and and it's funny I'm not going to go
as far as to say that that the
development of a fetus is necessarily an
aggressor on that but you're violating
somebody's um structural integrity their
bodily autonomy especially if they don't
want it at the end of the day the
process of pregnancy is going to be
violating your bodily autonomy to a
certain extent if you're okay with that
then that's completely fine you're okay
with that if you're not okay with that
you shouldn't be forced to continue with
that so I think that bio autonomy can be
limited in like shooting heroin but I
don't think it should be limited in that
if at any given point someone is to have
sex with you then you have to continue
with that and I think that if we are
going to say that oh I like the way you
phrase that someone is to have sex with
you not that you yeah because I no
because even though like rape is rare
right like what do we but like is a
fetus is a fetus any less of a person if
it's conceived through rape no and I
don't think that killing a baby who does
the crion so again so it's like if we're
to say that bodily autonomy isn't really
that important and uh and no it matters
within its proper place yeah rape is not
one of those yeah no that's a horrible
crime but killing a baby is not going to
undo a horrible crime it's just going to
compound that by adding another crime to
it it compounds it either way if you
have to carry to term and subject to
your body in your body autonomy to the
process that to begin it's a terrible
crime right so why is a one so it's it's
funny how we talk about oh equal value
equal life you're playing this calculus
game where you're saying well it's not
worth killing a baby that that's
completely no because you're no because
you're saying that this fetus has this
particular amount of value and we
shouldn't do this we shouldn't
circumvent or we it doesn't matter what
like bodily autonomy you're saying about
because at the end of the day you're
killing a Fus but when a woman is even
in the case of rape which admittedly is
rare even in the case of rape you're
saying well you know it's terrible crime
terrible crime but but what I'm saying
what I'm saying is that certain rights
are derivative of other rights and
certain rights are more fundamental so
so in this case the the conflict is not
between the rights of the woman and the
rights of the child but rather the right
to life and the right to you say bodily
autonomy which I don't think is a good
definition of Liberty but let's just
let's just say it is uh the the right to
life is not just one right among many
but it's the fundamental right without
which none of the other rights exist
think well the the reason is because if
you're not alive you you don't have the
ability to excise other you are alive
but what is the worth in being alive if
you don't have any of the other
rights you have the right to life even
if you can't kill if I say you don't
have the right to life but if I say you
do have the right to life but you don't
have the right to B autonomy or you
don't have the right to like protection
or anything to say right if you are
strung up and you're tortured by
somebody
right you're alive but I think that the
reason why we put so much value on this
right to which is why I wanted to ask
you about it is cuz we assume that life
is this deistic thing we take we tie a
lot of like like we tie a lot of like
theology or like like religious aspects
to the concept of being alive I think I
think that if you don't have life in
tandem with the other rights then your
life is not worth like that's not a
quality of life that we should saying s
suffering would uh kill our no because
I'm no Jesus it I I I admire how fast
you like backflip because my thing is
what I'm saying follow these ideas yeah
no but I'm saying you're not but I'm
saying um I'm not saying that because
someone's life entails suffering that
means that you just get killed you're
saying the of life if no I'm saying I'm
saying that why are we talking about oh
the right to life is so fundamental
above all the other rights but if you
don't have all the other rights sure
you're living but that's no quality of
life that you're living in the same I
think life is still good I don't think
if you're suffering even if you're an
immense amount that you should so if you
just have the right you think that life
is just inherently good whether or not
if you give someone the right to life
and no other rights at the end of the
day you're just breathing no yeah I I
don't think that suffering
underes someone could torture you
mentally torture you physically within
the inch of your life and that's
preferable than having being murdered
yeah yeah I think so because life always
involves some degree of suffering and uh
some people the rights that we have in t
in tandem with the right to life
decrease that degree of suffering yeah
perhaps I mean people not perhaps that's
a fact you can't have you can you can
get all the way up to being beat within
the ede of your life and as long as
you're still breathing you're good on
that I'm saying we need to have all of
them at the same time because without
one you would drastically increase the
amount do people have more rights today
than they did 50 years ago or fewer
rights I'd say more more rights are
people happier today than they were 50
years ago or less happy i' say more
happy well according to surveys that
measure happiness so take them for a
grain of salt people are significantly
less happy and women especially are both
significantly less happy as as relates
to men and in objective terms and we can
see this measured in other ways that are
a little more objective like like deaths
of Despair deaths of suicide drug
overdoses and the prescription of
anti-depressant that's that's again
that's a correlation causation thing
where you're saying oh because more
rights and like less Happ that must mean
that one cause the other no there are a
lot socioeconomic pressures and
everything that have gone into it since
the 1950s on top of that I'm pretty sure
a lot of women were lying about the
happiness in the 1950s because you
really didn't have rights why you would
think that why they wouldn't be lying
now why would they not be lying now
because they don't really face any
social as much Social persecution for
lying so you're just saying I just don't
want to believe that this this
chart humans are what do you mean what
chart
contradicts srep the chart that you're
even saying even if I just made up
everything I just said the chart isn't
even saying what you're saying it is cuz
you're saying because there are more
rights and look less happy that means
that more rights equals less happy can't
help but look I mean you're taking a
leap that isn't I you're bringing up I
don't believe that what we call rights
today really do constitute rights like
the right to abortion but I can't help
but notice that over the exact same time
period of the rise of feminism that
women's happiness has diminished not
only in line with the happiness of men
but also relative to men they become
even less happy than men who have also
become less happy and it would seem to
me look I'm not saying it would seem
likely that there might be a correlation
with the rise of uh the increase in
Black rights in Black Humanity happiness
has decreased I'm not black people have
more rights today do you're not sure
that black people have more well then
you agreed with me that America's racist
right I no I don't think that America's
I mean I agree with you on some things I
don't agree with you that America's
racist no you just said that we have no
black people don't have anywhere near
the right to life that they had before
roie Wade which is why more black babies
murdered in the room in New York City
born I got to teach you about some like
racial issues if you if you ever looked
into why that is that um more cuz I can
give you an actual uh correlation that
has a probably stronger likelihood of
being true the reason why a lot of black
people get way more abortions is because
lower socioeconomic status depend I'm
not saying why they get it or not I'm
just saying that they're they're Le less
likely to enjoy their right to life
they're less likely to have the right to
their mother and father I'm your frame
I'm going to operate in your framework
yeah they are very less likely to have a
right to that's a very sad thing so I
don't think
that's a product of systemic that's a
product of systemic racism I think it's
a product of liberalism is what I think
and I think it's a product of the very
yeah I think it's a product of the very
things that we are told actually give
black people more rights things like
abortion things like the breakdown of
the family which I think deprive people
we got told that the breakdown of the
family gives people more rights you guys
take the because the right to divorce
and yeah and the right to sexual
promiscuity and sex out of wedlock okay
wait oh jeez you throw like so many
things at the same time where it's kind
of like I don't think yeah I'm I don't
know how you do it it's like AK but it's
like uh I don't think that you I think
when you're talking about the rights of
or the the breakdown of the family and
everything I don't think that that's
something that it's also like heavily
steeped in this kind of solar view like
this one view of how a family can
operate and I think that when you talk
about mass incarceration when you talk
about all the different social like
phenomena that black people have been
put through War on drugs and everything
black people are not over incarcerated
relative to the crime that was committed
by that demographic it's not I know
there's a myth that it's it is but it
isn't black people are roughly nine and
a half times as likely as white people
to be incarcerated in the United States
which is a shocking number this is
according to just in the wake of George
Floyd the Minnesota Bureau of uh
criminal incarceration or whatever it's
called published these statistics about
n and a half uh but black people commit
crimes General crime at roughly nine
times the of white people and serious
crimes rough 10 times the rate yeah and
murder at roughly 50 times the rate and
robbery at roughly 107 times that in you
Sayang murder at 50 times a raid gave me
everything I need to know about how
you're lying about those statistics
because took as a 1350 saying that black
people commit 50% of murders and
everything that doesn't mean murder at a
rate 50 times higher no I'm saying per
capita black people commit murder at a
I'm not saying that the majority of
black people commit murder I'm I'm
saying that black people are 50 times
more likely than white people to commit
murder I I I'm not going to lie I don't
think that you're honestly representing
those sta I am it's from the Minnesota
Government the statistics have come out
just recently in the last couple of
years furthermore you can see that when
it comes to likelihood of being arrested
MH for a crime white people are 70% more
likely to be arrested for any crime than
black people and uh white people 60%
more likely to be from uh the Minnesota
Bureau of Criminal I forget the I forget
the last part but whatever their uh
justice statistics department is it
comes from them and uh white people are
60% more likely to be arrested for
serious crimes there's one more likely
or do they make up 60% and 70% of the
arrest more likely for they're more
likely there's one exception which is
weapons crimes where black people are
more likely to be arrested than white
people but yeah it's just a myth though
the notion that black people are
unjustly hunted down by the police or
something it's just completely made up
um I think that when you're talking
about first of all that it's not even
Tak into account over policing cuz okay
I think we have a crime problem in the
country which means we probably have
crime problem have we always had a crime
problem well crime has spiked it was it
was really bad in the early 90s and it
decreased because of prop Poli and then
it's increased again that's crazy
because the decrease that happened in
the early 90s started decreasing before
even all the the crazy mass
incarceration policies ended up going
into effect there's a decrease that was
there's a lot of social factors that
contributed to why crime spiked in the
90s but the decrease started before any
actual policy even became implemented
and then we start
we started locking up people at a higher
rate as opposed to like uh the crimes
that they being committed and we were
locking them up for much longer in
comparison to other countries the crime
rate remain crimes for stuff for like
burglary and everything um and were
served at a I think 60% longer in the
United States as opposed to countries
with similar good I like locking up
burglars I feel a lot sa EX for that
doesn't fix anything it does because it
keeps the criminals in jail and then
they don't burglarize my house okay I
think that um I think that that's a a
very simplistic way of looking at uh
criminal justice because it does keep I
have a simple view of Criminal Justice
we should lock up the bad guys and
protect the good guys what is a bad guy
the people who commit crimes and we
should lock them up after they have due
process it's a a violation of the law is
it always just to lock someone up viol
well an unjust law is no law at all
which is why oh it's a species of
violence so do you know what jury
nullification is I I do know what jury
nullification the concept of when a jury
will have reasonable that someone's
guilty they will quit him anyway because
a lotj a lot of times they believe that
a uh unjust law is but I think laws
against burglary are perfectly just
something like marijuana is something
that jurries tend to nullify on because
of the disproportionate impact virtually
no one is in prison in the United States
for simple possession of marijuana some
sometimes they take plea deals but it it
it's exceedingly rare for that to happen
when you talk the vast majority of it's
It's dependent on the amount of
marijuana because a lot of times it can
be simple possession but if you're CAU
with Mount of marijuana they assume that
you're a distributor also and charge big
brick of marijuana yeah you might just
be a big glutton for pot but but it's
usually plea deals for people who are I
don't think when you talk about keep the
bad people away that's like a fourth
grade level understanding cuz like yeah
you can keep them away but again then
what happens when they have to come back
into society yeah you have to
reintegrate them after they've paid
their debt to society yeah but again
then that completely depends on what we
consider to be bad because if we're
locking someone up disproportionate
amount of burglary murder you know petty
theft assault is that what it is because
I'm pretty sure that the vast majority
of people are uh who are in jail are
awaiting trial and the vast majority of
people who are in jail I'm pretty sure
there's more people in jail than in
prison most of them are waiting for
trial and a lot of them are not intense
felony convictions a lot of times it's
victimless crime or it can be like
there's no such thing as a victimless
crime over 60% of like marijuana
possession no that creates all sorts of
victims but how because you're you're
pedaling drugs on society which how do
you know that they're pedaling drugs and
a and if they are pedaling drugs that
there's a difference between like a
recreational one that is used that
doesn't necessarily cause any harm or
one that's laced like if you're lacing
it then yeah you should it's pretty bad
yeah I think marijuana just causes harm
I think drugs generally are bad that's
why we have laws against them but but
over 60% of inmates in state prisons are
there for violent crime for serious
crimes they're not there for dime bags
in state prison yeah I mean when it
comes to but the majority of prisoners
are in state prisons not federal prisons
yeah the vast majority of like when it
comes to drug it's not like drug crimes
make up like a a minority of um of uh
prison convictions yes but I'm saying
when it comes to how these people end up
in circumstances that they do what what
courses in their lives I know a lot of
people um like if you kill your rapist
you end up you still get charged for
that or whatever maybe you do you do
still depends on the circumstance
there's plenty of there's plenty of
women who who uh and i' I'm actually
reading stories about them right now
vigilant
on top of that mental health things that
go into one's propensity to commit crime
and everything so it's like just saying
the bad people go away and doing nothing
about what we consider bad and how agree
scenario that you it's just a very
Draconian thing if you think that we
lock up people good well I mean you talk
about the breakdown of the black family
when we went with breakdown of the
family broadly but especially when we
look at the Lock up the bad people after
you all but ensured that they'd be
committing a disproportionate amount of
crime by locking up family men we're not
we're not locking up to Michael no we're
not locking uping to statistics we're
not yeah okay and yeah cuz black fathers
are I think four to five times more
likely even when unmarried to play with
to clothe bathe and be there for their
children as compared to White and
Hispanic fathers but we still have the
myth of black fatherlessness what does
that mean that mean we still have the
myth of black fatherlessness right yeah
so there are I don't know about the myth
I mean of black children born out of
wedlock three4 of black children almost
are born out of wedlock in the United
States yeah and even then why is that a
bad thing well well for one reason it's
a great predictor of bad outcomes down
the road single Parenthood is out of
wedlock is not out of wedlock just means
that the parents are not married and
that's the statistics I was telling you
about despite not being married black
fathers are still more likely than any
other demographic to be there and raise
their children but we still have this
myth in our brains that black people are
why don't they get married why don't
they get married there's many reasons
for not getting married a lot of times
it can be expenses cu go down to you go
down to the court that doesn't
necessarily like change anything there's
even studies it's not expensive to get
married yeah even then it still doesn't
really change anything black father
black families that do have married
parents still are have way less income
and way less upward Mobility than white
parents who are married anyway yeah but
you're not you're not distinguishing
between married couples and unmarried
couples dising uniting two incomes
together can be a good thing but I'm
saying you don't necessar marriage is
about more than income wouldn't you
agree for me like in a value sense yeah
I'd say like I'd prefer to get married
but that doesn't mean that people who
aren't getting married are somehow wrong
or immoral or well statistically their
kids are more likely to end up in prison
more likely to end up on drugs and more
likely to not make a lotone single
Parenthood that's defined in law as
being out of wedlock that's what single
parent it is no it's not well yeah they
they don't take into account couples
that are still together but just not
married those stats are from people who
are solely who have sole custody it's
either a single mother or a single
father that yes being raised by one
parent is going to drastic
your married
not that go away if they were raising
you already they just weren't married it
does refers to out of wedlock not merly
to mothers who never see the father of
their children it refers to single
parents there is no statistic that out
of wedlock as in the parents are still
there because when it says out of
wedlock it could be oh so you're saying
there's no way to measure the parents
who are there so you're saying there is
no statistic for the point that you're
trying to prove right you mean you
saying there's no statistic
because sta that do in the statistics
that do include the parents that are
still together just not married show How
likely black fathers are to be with
their dad show their likelihood of
positive outcome the marriage
certificate isn't getting them such
better socioeconomic outcomes because it
doesn't matter whether or not you are
legally unioned as one uh income or like
two separate incomes in one household if
you guys are both working and bringing
in income for your children you just
don't have a marriage certificate I'm a
little skeptical cuz I haven't seen
those studies but perhaps you'll send
them
I look forward to that uh in any case
we've gone about an hour over but I've
enjoyed it very much JJ thank you very
much for coming on did I did I convince
you of anything no I don't think so I
think I think the the the framing and
the stuff was a little bit little bit
wonky okay all right maybe next time
I'll have better luck maybe next time
maybe next time thank you JJ thank you
very much for watching see you next
[Music]
time